Joining
the meeting. Joining the meeting.
Brett, can you hear us okay?
Yes, I can. Thank you. Great,
we can hear you too. Thanks.
There it is. Wasn't working.
All right. Welcome to the City Council meeting.
This is our work session, June 2nd at 4 PM. We're actually 4:03
getting started, and, uh, we will start—
actually, I want to start by making, uh, letting everybody know, uh, we do have
Brent and Zach online, correct? Correct. And, uh,
they are joining remote at a conference. Uh, we actually
have a lot of staff as well. They're at a water conference and working
on some of those issues with the entire state. We have
Representative Schmoller, we're trying to work this out. So we'll excuse them and welcome
them online. Also, for anybody in
the public that was wondering about item 17A,
that's the Horizon item with
Scott Hazard, that's been pulled. So we're not going to be
discussing that tonight. It was a public hearing as well. So if you were coming
for that public hearing, that item has been pulled.
With that, we'll go ahead and get started with some of our discussion items.
And the first one is an employee policy and procedure update.
It has to do with cell phones and the issuance of cell phones. And we
have Angela Valenzuela from our Human Resources
who's going to present this. Thank you, Mr.
Chairman. So you have the line
that's being taken out from F under mobile phones.
We're just going to strike that first line there because it
talks specifically about city-issued
devices being given to all employees. And what this would do is
be optional. An employee can elect
to continue with their city-issued phone. I don't know if you can see that.
Or to use their own phone and only have to carry one around,
and then they would receive a stipend equal to the amount the city pays,
which is around $41.
That was easy. So, you know, this is something we've been talking about
since January, I believe. Basically, if you
want a second phone or feel like you need a second phone, That's what it
costs the city is about four. We went back and forth between forty and
fifty dollars a month, kind of depending. But that's what it costs the city.
So you can have the option to carry a second phone or
get a reimbursement to use your own phone.
And then we just their number would have to be made available to the
council and the staff. I think that's kind of the only
change. So I will. Ask if there's any
questions or discussion on how you guys want to see that handled so we can
bring this forward. I think the only question I have about that is just,
I'm assuming that they're going to have to provide their telephone number as
the contact number. Correct. It'll have to be listed. Yeah,
there'll be some internal policies that we would make sure that they follow and know,
and that, that's one of the things that they have to provide that phone number
and be available at all times, just as if they had a city-issued phone So
the second question is probably more specific to maybe like mayor,
city manager, some of our senior-level
staff members. Are we going to do their own personal telephone numbers for
those numbers as well, or do we feel like that there's some sense
in keeping that number the same so that when there's a changeover of that
position that the people are calling one number, not trying to find a new number?
I mean, it's optional. You can choose either one. And so the mayor's
always had a phone. Since I came on in
January, I chose not to take that phone. I just wanted one. We still
have that number, if I'm not mistaken, and it's just not—
nobody's packing that phone. So can we port it? So that number's
still active and we just port it to Jared's phone? That way, if they
call that number, it'll read as his personal number if he decides to do that.
And then the next 2 or 3 mayors, that number is still the same.
And if they want to use their own phone number, great. If not, that number
is still coming to them. We would need to— we would be paying for 2
phones essentially at that point though, because we would need to keep that number active.
You're talking like $3 a month. You can put it— there's holding companies
that will hold that number and forward it. Oh, just hold the number, not keep
it active? Yeah, well, the number stays active and they put it in basically a
bank. We can look into that. Yeah, that would just— that number,
if you— some reason we got all kinds of feedback today, but if it was,
uh, if that was the case In order to forward it, that's different
than the hold. The hold just freezes the number. It would have to be an
active line, which at the minimum I think is $9, $10, $11 maybe.
But that's trying to keep the confusion, you know what I mean? Yeah, I know
what you're saying. So really the question is, is that a desire of council
to do that? I don't want to have 2 phones. I think that sucks.
Would the next guy want that? Who knows, right? I doubt it. I doubt that
they want to do that. There has to be a way for
them to be able to call a number to get a hold of the mayor,
just like there's a mayor email address. We do have a desk.
There's a landline that goes to the mayor's office with its own number, if I'm
not mistaken. Chaz usually takes that,
but I'm seeing nods that say that we have a city number and we have
the mayor's desk, and then Chaz usually takes care of those. I don't I've
never heard of Ring. It's forwarded to Chas's desk.
But we have the landline, I think, which is probably the
real answer. That's what I'm looking for, so that it's that plan, that's fine.
So then that satisfies that if we just keep the landline?
Yeah. Okay. So my question is, how recently
have we evaluated the cell phone contract to see that we're
getting a good deal monetarily? Kim is actually questioning that
right now as we speak. She started getting into the weeds.
Of the bill. She was looking at some of that stuff. There's a lot of
competition among cell phone carriers right now, and I would
be— I believe we could probably get that price down to
a lower number. It's been within the last 24 months that we transitioned
to T-Mobile in terms of— would have been the last time that we
looked at that. The primary reason at that time for transitioning had
to do with coverage. So we do have some key areas within the community
that we have some coverage issues, and at that time for us,
T-Mobile was going to be able to meet those needs better than we had.
But I did, as in review of this policy, I did recently
reach out to them for the current contracted government rates, and we are looking
at that as well. But it was in the last 24 months.
Okay, can we build into this policy that there's an automatic
requirement to revisit This, you know, what we're paying,
and then to have it adjusted, whether up or down. I mean, because maybe these
services go up, then it needs to go up. If it goes down, we want
it to go down. We have proposed in the policy that we wouldn't set the
rate. The rate would be reviewed annually as part of the budget process,
and that the employee would only be able to receive the amount
based on what our contract is. We do want to avoid that there would be
any additional cost to the city. So again, if we make any changes, then that
rate would also change, but it would be reviewed annually as part of the budget
process. And that is identified in the policy.
Our internal policy reads on that portion 5,
monthly stipend structure, city employee cell phone stipend will be set by Finance
Department according to the standard contract service rate with the city's wireless service
provider as of July 1st each fiscal year. So it would, it would change.
So I have a follow-up question to that, and I just wanted to make one
other comment. What if the service that the The employee is using is not adequate?
It's not what, sir? Adequate. What if they have a cheaper service,
therefore they're not available in important parts of the city?
We have the ability to require the employee, so it is again,
the employee could, but if they can't meet our requirements for the need,
then we would require them to have a city-issued phone. That's, yeah,
that's, so that's the first part where I was heading with that, and then Angela,
read that part again that you just read. I forgot my question, but if you
read that part you just read, Angela will remind me what it was. City employee
cell phone stipend will be set by Finance Department. Yes, that reminds me.
What if the plan that they pay for is less than
that and our stipend is now exceeding that and giving them money back?
That would be what the city was paying for them either way.
So we're paying for their whole bill plus they're getting extra money?
That's what I'm saying. What if their bill is lower? Essentially.
I think, I mean, that's up to the council, but I think if the stipend's
a stipend and someone finds an adequate, which is the key, service for
less money, then if they carried a city phone, it would cost us either way.
So if they have the ability to do that for less,
I highly doubt it, but the other option would
be paid that same amount for a city phone anyway. So I don't know that
we'd be I don't think anybody's
looking to make $2 a month or something off a cell phone. That's probably not
their focus. But if they're finding something that's drastically
that much cheaper, I'm going to guess that it's probably not adequate either. And then
they'd be forced to not get a stipend and carry a phone.
I just want to make sure the contract's reviewed annually. As well,
just to make sure we're saving money. We were with Verizon, I think,
before. That's been looked at a lot recently. That's still
been the case, but we'll continue to
do that. I think Carson and Evan have both been on that.
Did you— I just— when we had Verizon, it was awful.
Like, if we called anyone on staff and they were in the building, if they
weren't like standing on one leg, With like their hand in the air, they couldn't
have a phone call here. So I think, yes, we should
do an evaluation of the cost, but I also
think we have to go with what's actually adequate,
that word that we talked about before. So that's really important to me.
And if Verizon isn't going to have enough coverage here, then they just don't get
our business. So. At the time when we went with T-Mobile, I remember it's
because they were putting the towers out here specifically. and promised us
that coverage, and we've had it. It's been pretty good. And I know
Councilmember Huish has talked about it, and we've actually asked Carson
to look into adding Verizon towers. Verizon wanted to, and I think we approved one
at the high school that just hasn't been done. So there's still—
we're gonna lean into that a little bit and see if we can't get other
carriers out there, both for the public and just to broaden
that network. I think even Marcus had mentioned that a
lot of the service issues had to do more with traffic and the amount
of calls that were on the— I can't remember what they call it, but it
was basically traffic, right? Too many people on the tower, something like
that. So anyway,
online, either Councilmember Huish, Councilmember Wright,
have anything to add? Nothing for me,
Mayor. Okay,
moving forward with that, I suppose. Hang on, Mayor, I think Zach had one.
I'm just trying to get him unmuted. Hold on,
Zach, you should be able to talk now.
I'm starting to think the gremlins live with Zach because last time I always—
isn't he the one that had to call in?
Yeah. I see
his bubble moving, but it's not coming through.
Brett's— Councilman Wright's phone works, so I don't know what's the deal
with one of those other chairs. Yeah, he's not with Verizon or T-Mobile.
We'll come back to that in just a second. Write down
your questions, if you will, and we'll see if we can't get it working.
If you'll let me know if you think you've got it sorted out, we'll come
back to that. Is there any other discussion? Are we okay moving forward with it
the way that is, bringing it as an item on
the next— here in the next few agendas anyway?
Councilmember Whiting, do you want something to
be added in here that it needs to be reviewed like every 12 to 18
months? So there's a little bit of wiggle room? Yep, I think so.
Yeah. So 12 months, I think.
I mean, if we're going to reset the contract, if we're going to renew the
rate or look at the rate once a year, I think we shop
out options once a year. Don't you think? I think there might be.
I don't know if Carson wants to speak to this or just tell us,
but I think, you know, a lot of times when you get a phone or
something, I don't know what the city contract is, but sometimes you have to do
minimum 2 years. You know, so that there could be— or you have
to buy those, right? Isn't it usually knocked out? There could— I don't know
about the other city town. I mean, I know personally in my business, the 2
different bills, but do we have any kind of— I'll let him speak to that,
but it is a major— it's a pretty big overhaul changing if we were to
change every year. When we have done it, it's a lot of work, and then
we're changing everybody's number. They don't all— we're not always able to get everybody's number
back, so it's about everybody going through and changing the numbers, changing them online.
All of that stuff also. Sorry,
so what was the main question that we have? So how often
should we review the rate that we're paying for the cell phones?
Cell phones is probably a separate category where we do want to do that more
often. I would think annually. Most of our contracts,
we should be doing those probably every 5 years at minimum.
But in this case of phones, there are a lot of moving pieces
that are probably a bit more tricky. For instance, we had had quite a few
of the different functions for the city that had asked for mobile
devices, so like iPads or Surfaces that they can use out in the field.
And so some of those just barely got put on that bill.
So it's all one kind of conglomerate. So it's not just strictly cell phones.
But I do definitely agree with council that we could shop around and definitely find
something that's cheaper. And I know Kim really is doing a fantastic job already kind
of spearheading and chasing that down. I think if our plan is to
let people use their own phones, then the changing numbers is no longer a problem.
That's going to happen often anyway, so that probably isn't an issue
anymore. Yeah, from my point of view, the ones that we are worried about are
the key numbers. So like with the mayor or any administrative staff that you want
that routinely more for the mantle and not necessarily for— Yeah,
that's what I was asking earlier. I think the desire of the mayor and maybe
even others is uses their own number and not worried about that number, uses a
stat line. So I think to that point, I don't think that's even an issue
anymore. I think we can shop every year because the numbers don't matter anymore.
Well, I think the real question is
really about expense. So can we look into— I think so. I'm trying to
navigate what it is that we're looking to put in the code or in the
policy compared to what we're looking to
accomplish. Even if we found Okay,
we look into it annually and our total bill is $1,000 for all
phones, but we could get this other one for $998. I don't
think we want to switch for $2 or something. You're not asking to take the
lowest bid, you're saying evaluate it. So what is the metrics or what are you
hoping to get out of that evaluation? If there's a significant
savings, it depends on the quality as well. Sometimes we don't always take the lowest
bid. It's what's quality. Yes, we evaluate,
but what are you hoping to get out of the evaluation? I think that's it,
right? There has to be an evaluation of service,
price, phone number available. If that's something that
matters still at that point, because maybe it doesn't. Maybe everybody's just done that.
Yeah, and to that, I think what Councilmember Clark was getting
at is, did you want to add that to a policy that it has to
be? And if it does, then what's the reporting? Does that even have to be
reported, or what is it we're trying to accomplish? I think most
of the time when we're looking at contracts like that, we want them to bring
3 to evaluate, the 3 best.
That's usually best practices, at least having 3
quotes. And then just remember that the, you know,
sometimes that $2 savings is going to cost you $100 in
staff time just to change them,
right? I mean, it's— but we're going to be adding more employees and more employees,
and at some point those $2 Makes a big difference. Yeah,
well, what I'm saying is then you take every one of those employees that come
in once a year to get a new phone, import their number over, you just
wasted an 8-hour shift to save $2 a month. I'm going to just spitball
here, but I think most city employees will take credit and not think so.
So I don't think it's going to be a big issue. Okay, that's— I
just want to make sure that if you're asking for this to be in the
policy, what it is that we're asking for, an evaluation that comes back with Bring
3 business— that they've pre-evaluated.
That wouldn't actually be in the policy from what we're proposing. That's why
we wanted to have the discussion to see what— the only part of the policy
that was changing was that one part that's being redlined because that's the only part
of the policy that mentions mobile phones. So the other parts
are all like our internal procedures and making sure when the employees are signing off
that they're going to be responsible for Making
sure the phone works, that they're responsive, all of that stuff. That's the other policy.
So we weren't really addressing— No, I think we're aware of that. It's open now.
To Craig's point, why not address it now?
If we're going to talk about it, let's talk about making it a policy.
So if the council would like to give us direction in regards
to how often, that is a purchasing matter, and I'd recommend
that we address that not in the employee handbook because That's the policy section.
That's what we're addressing right now is the policy for employee handbook. So when we
start to break it off, we talk about we want to have our purchasing contracts
removed— reviewed more frequently. I recommend
that if you do want it in a written policy, that we would address that
in our purchasing policy from that
particular standpoint. But in general, these are items that we
would be reviewing. Again, we did We did put that provision in the handbook that
we would look at it annually in terms of that cost.
Every contract that we have to some extent, unless we have a multi-year contract,
is one that we have to review as part of the budget process in preparing
for those costs. That's what I was getting at, and that was much better.
That's what I was trying to figure out. So it's talking about purchasing. Does that
satisfy this? Yeah. So what do we need to do to add it
to our purchasing?
So it may already be addressed in there. So what we could do is we
could go in and look to see where we're at. What does the purchasing policy
include specifically as it relates to the timeline for any service agreements?
If you want them to have a shorter duration than
what we currently have, we would need to also just look at our T-Mobile one
to see. A lot of times those are a 2-year type
of a contract. Okay. I think he's made it pretty clear
what we're looking for. So if it's in the other policies, let's get that in
there. I'm in support of 12 months,
review it, bring it back through according to whatever
purchasing policy is, and let's make sure that we have the best deal. Even— the
thing is, it's going to go lower. You're going to have less phones. If you're
going to do this, you're going to have a lot less phones, which means our
costs are going to go up. That's likely. That's the likely scenario.
Councilmember Huish might be hearing set, so he should be able
to speak now. Okay, can you hear me now?
Yes, we can. All right, sweet.
Awesome. I was just going to weigh in my thoughts. At our
company, we just do a $60 a month reimbursement.
It's pretty straightforward and simple if you're using your own cell
phone number. You just said a reimbursement for $65. I would
propose a $60 reimbursement.
Did you, did you say $50 with a 5 or $60 with a 6?
6-0. So, so you want the reimbursement to be $60?
Does anyone— I'm still good
with the $41 just based on your math because you're probably getting a better rate
due to the The city's probably getting a better rate due to the number of
phones we have. And would that also— sorry, I think the $60 probably takes
into account the fact that you had to purchase the phone. Us paying
$41, is that just what it costs us for the
line, or does that include the cost broken up of the actual phone?
I believe we get the phones as part of our deal.
Also, when we get the phones as part of the deal, is it a 2-year
commitment? Because if that's the case, then we shouldn't We shouldn't set it for 12
months, we should set it for 24 months. Correct. Well, so the way that they
break it down is that like if you order a device that's kind of out
of generation, 1 or 2 removed, they basically give you the device free,
but then it is the contract on the line with that device that then
is charged. Um, so the number being reflected at
a lower rate is because we get those devices basically, hey, you're government, here you
go. Um, as kind of a— stipend-y
type thing on there and to make it alluring, right? Whereas very
much to your point, if you do have to go and purchase your own device,
it is kind of on your own dime, your own wear and tear.
And so to Councilmember Huish's point, at least in my past experience
in private sector, a lot of the time whenever there is a BYOD or bring
your own device scenario like this, it will be a little higher than even what
the— I think that's a good point. Company would pay just because they are fully
aware of, you know, hey, and then it puts the onus on the person
that's decided to enroll versus the company even having to
go through all the, the man hours, the maintenance, all that. Um, there would
just be a simple, from a technical standpoint for me, employees would still have to
enroll in an employee-owned device thing that basically puts profiling
on there to kind of manage certain things that way. Um,
but otherwise— But otherwise, Yeah, you're right on the money.
So I think where I would say, and Councilmember Huish,
just correct me if I'm wrong, the policy actually reads
just whatever it costs the city rather than put a dollar amount in there.
It was currently $41,000, but that could fluctuate year
over year. It could go up, it could go down. And if that's in there,
then it's always just going to be that number. And I think the safer bet
is let that go. Like right now, it might be more of
a window between $40 and $60, it might land on
$50 if that's what the cost of phones are this year. A future year might
be less. So wouldn't the policy just be whatever it's saving the city
from not having to provide that line, and that would be the pass-through?
Correct. That's what the intent was.
But currently that's $41. Yeah, I mean,
because you're providing phones now. When those phones drop, that price is going to So
it's a moving target no matter what. Yeah, well,
you're going to have less phones, your cost is going to go up, so then
you're paying a premium price for people to have an individual phone. I still think
it's going to be cheaper than it is right now. Probably is. That's why
I say just pick a number. I mean, trying to chase the 41 or 62
or whatever that is, and usually, I mean, at least in the private sector,
they're not looking to pay your entire phone bill. They're going to give you a
cost of being able to use it for work. So make it $50,
and if that goes up, it goes up, but you're not paying for most of
your personal phone bill. You're right. Yeah, my phone's $119 a month or
something like that. I don't know whatever that is, but so it's, it's, uh,
that's not for your own individual use though. Yeah, $50 for one phone
is what the usual one is. So is that better
than just doing whatever's saving the city? You want to pick a number?
Is that what everybody agrees with?
It's arbitrary anyway, so just choose a number and say
that's what the stipend is going to be. My only concern with that is the
potential that we will be— it will cost us more than we currently budget
for our cell phone plan by picking a number that
is higher than what we currently pay. The objective was it's out
of convenience for the employee to not have to carry 2 phones, and if they
elect That they can either— if they don't want to deal with the pricing,
then they can choose to carry a city-issued phone. If they want to
only carry one phone out of convenience, then the cost and the expense would
not be any more than what it would have cost the city to have them
on their plan. Our plan
isn't based off volume, it's based on government rate. And so
reducing the number of people on our plan would not increase the
rate that we are paying for the lines we currently have. Answer the question.
You know what the rate is and that's not going to change, then make that
the standard rate. Come on.
I just feel like we went full circle. Like, so basically
the dollar amount's determined by what it costs the city and we're
just going to go with that. Yeah, I— my only reservation is
that I think it probably needs to be At least every 24
months, not 12, because I feel like as long as it takes us
to do a full evaluation of stuff, you're 6 months in and then 6 months
later you're starting the process over again. So I would— maybe
there's a way to just check what rates are and then there's
every 2 years you do like a full evaluation. But I don't know
if doing it every year is practical for manpower. Are they making
us sign a 2-year agreement for a government contract?
Does anybody know
that? Unsure at the moment. I know in the past when I used to,
the first time we had T-Mobile was a 2-year agreement at that time. With the
government pricing? Yes. But that was way back. Whatever the
contract is, that's what it has to be evaluated at. And maybe that's the tempo
is just whenever the contract is due, we get it shopped out every time,
bring 3 options to the Council makes a new decision,
and maybe we go to a 5-year contract because we get a great deal.
Maybe we go to a 2-year contract, maybe it's a 1. So it needs to
be— anytime a contract is up, needs to be renewed and
competitively bid out. I like that. I like just kind of using
what makes sense.
So, so what I understand is we're going to Use
the number that the city is— Okay.
Whatever, just follow what the contract is. If it's a 2-year contract,
and so the wording needs to be that when the contract is going to expire,
it's got to come back for approval with City Council. Okay. That's on the purchasing
part, on the reimbursement part, whatever it is, so that they can get their stipend.
Okay. That's what the city said. That's what the cost is.
Okay. Perfect. I think we've got that one. Councilmember Huish,
are we good?
Yeah, I'm good. Thank you. Okay. And Councilmember Rice, still no questions?
I'll put it on the stand here. Okay.
Perfect. We'll move on to item 1B, which is another policies
and procedures manual update. This is Kimberly
Roosch has about the administrative services.
Credit cards. Oh yeah, that's right. I hope Councilmember Wright's
got a lot of notes on this one. So Mayor and Council,
this is an item that we're bringing back that was brought before the council back
in December that was tabled at the time. And so we're trying to get that
back before you to be able to review.
Based on the feedback and some of the information that we had at that time
too, a lot of the questions stemmed around I had used a term for
credit card administrator. Who would that actually be and what would that look like?
So in the revised redlines that we've done here as
well, we have just included it. And currently it is designated
as the city treasurer or designee has the responsibility
for issuing those cards and is the manager over that credit card purchasing
program for us on behalf of the city.
Most of the items in there are clerical in nature to
be able to identify kind of the reflect the current practices
and what we're doing there. The specific change that
we have in regards to items that are allowed versus not allowed
for a particular change is we did add a
provision under the section that talks about the purchasing
of gift cards has been strictly prohibited in the past. We added
a provision that it's restricted unless preauthorization is approved.
Our purpose for wanting to be able to add that in there,
again, we don't deal with gift
cards very often, but in the event that we did do one, we have internal
documents that require gift card purchase authorization
that would have to be identified. The recipient of the gift card
has to sign it and acknowledge it because it does run through our payroll system.
There are IRS fringe benefit tax implications,
and so we capture that as part of that. But rather
than it just being strictly prohibited, we wanted to have a provision
that allowed it to be available based on preauthorization.
I just had a thought. Mm-hmm. Is there
anything in our policy— I just looked to see if I saw anything that
We want to put in there that prevents them from using that card number as
an autopay.
Yeah, I don't recall that there's anything specifically in there, but that is something that
we could add that would designate that as being
prohibited. Or could it be something with permission? Because sometimes
you get an autopay discount,
so especially when it comes to certain bills. We— there's nothing
that's in there. as I'm able to pause long enough to start to think about
the transactions that I've seen come through on some of these. So, we do have
some that are currently set up on an autopay nature.
I wanted to try to give an example. One that I remember before, I don't
know if it still exists, might have been like on the communications side. Yes.
There are certain applications where we're paying a $10
monthly fee for something. If we have a subscription for
For example, I believe we have an employee who has a subscription for like a
business application related to ChatGPT, and it has a monthly charge that requires
it to be attached to that. We do have a few that are designated
that way for that use. I guess the main thing is just where are the
parameters of that? I mean, if it's just authorization to be able to do something,
that probably ought to be in there, because that can absolutely be a problem if
somebody's done that and we didn't Leave the— I say company,
that's not the right word. Leave the city, they're no longer working for you,
you've got a recurring charge. So we
do have receipts that are required. Yes, in the event that an employee
were, we can have that included in our offboarding practices
that we would have, because we have some provisions already that in
terms of when an employee is terminated and turning that in and making sure that
we have all the receipts. Receipts and stuff that we could include,
you know, as part of our offboarding experiences to make sure that we are reviewing
automatic transactions. Depending on what it
is, those would potentially stay the same. We would just have to transfer them to
a different card. That was
my one question.
Councilmember Wright, I know you had a lot of questions on this one in the
past. Have anything today?
Thank you, Mayor. I do have just one question. Number one, well, number one,
I want to thank him really for identifying the treasurer or designee as
the person who's responsible. That was really one of my big hangups last time we
looked at this. And then just ask a question regarding the gift card
certificates. It says unless pre-authorized by city administration.
Who would be— who would be allowed then to authorize those
purchases of the gift cards? The city administration doesn't define any individual,
or at least to me it doesn't.
It's pretty broad. I'd like to tighten that up and really identify who we
want to give that authority to.
So internally for us, one of the ways we
looked at it previously was whether we were going to restrict it to the
Human Resources Department from making those purchases and being able to distribute
them. In terms of authorization, for the most part, we can designate whoever
you want. Right now it is an authorization that is running through the finance.
It would be the same thing. It would be running through the city treasurer.
So the city treasurer would be the one reviewing that based on their request,
what it is that they're asking for to
make that purchase and why. It does require
on the form that it has to be signed by the employee's department head authorizing
that as well, that they support that request before it
comes forward. I would really like to see— I mean, I like that. I think
giving it to the city treasurer is the person. I think we should identify that
city admin, which means the city treasurer.
And I also think included in that, there needs to be a sign-off by
human resources so that we know that the tax implications are being
tracked. So we
do have that sign-off that happens on the actual gift card policy
forms that we have. So they have to get preauthorization, which includes
sign-off as that passes through those different areas to ensure
that it is being withheld. And the employee recipient has to
sign it too, that they're acknowledging. And that guarantees that we don't have gift
cards that are being purchased and then retained by an individual purchasing them.
It's an internal practice that we would, we would have in terms of that acknowledgment
and ensuring that we know who the recipient,
um, is and would be able to identify if we have frequent purchases
to individuals that were occurring. With that explanation,
Kimberly, then I don't have any issues with that. Thank you. I think everything else
looks really great. You've done a good job of buttoning it up for us.
So do these credit cards accrue any points And
if they do, who benefits from that?
We do receive actual reimbursement or
a rebate that comes back to the city. It gets receipted in
as miscellaneous income in the general fund when we have those come in.
So it comes to the city, not to the employer? Correct. Okay,
then I have one, uh, perhaps wording change on G9.
So it talks about prohibiting, uh, Credit card payments
or— Yeah, prohibiting credit card use with consultants.
Then gives you a list of architects, engineers, attorneys, attorney's fees.
What we may want to put in there on 9 is saying consultants
including but not limited to the following.
Because there are other consultants we have. We have lobbyists. We have a whole host
of consultants that I think that may fall out of the—
the ones defined by 8, 8, 8, 8.
So you may say including but not limited to
the following. And I think that will open up a broader
understanding of any consultant as opposed to just
only those listed in 8. What if
you put something that says board might counsel approval?
Well, I think that's part of the administrative process.
Probably able to wrap that line with that, because I think
they're trying to keep it narrow. You don't want to open that up where they
can be used broadly rather than going through their normal purchasing process.
But if you have just a way to be able to bracket that and say,
where did you just read that from? So 99G
under G. I do want to clarify too that credit cards
are simply a payment method, and it does not. They still have to follow
all the same purchasing requirements regardless of the payment method
of a credit card. So in the— typically too, when you're dealing with
the consultants or stuff, then those are going
to be greater than, you know, $5,000. It would require a
purchase order. Typically for the consultant-type things, we've gone to bid or gotten
quotes or done things like that. So just to make sure that you know too
that a credit card does not provide Preclude them from having to follow any of
the requirements. They are still subject to all the purchasing policy stipulations.
Yeah,
I think that that sorry I missed the first part
of that. So this is the prohibited list. He's probably right. Not but not limited
to. It's probably not bad to put in there. And then
we're just going to I mean like when we designate it
that way. It does. We would treat it similar to
if something happened and we saw it come through, we would classify
that as a consultant. But maybe the card user didn't think that was a
consultant. It would just initiate like, we want to
make sure and clarify for you that you understand that
we would classify this. When they are called out specifically,
it makes it really clear. When it just says anything else— It
does leave it open to interpretation about what may be classified as a consultant
service or not. From just as a card issue, like a cardholder,
we'd want to make sure that we were aware of that
from any steps that we took from a
violation of the policy.
Okay. Councilmember Huish has some comments.
Yeah, this was more just a clarification, and I
was hoping, Kim, that maybe you could dispel any myths. But the question is,
today every credit card used in the city
is assigned to an individual. In other words, are there any community
cards that are in a drawer that anyone can use if they need to run
to Home Depot? Could you just maybe dispel that myth? Yes.
So every single card is issued to an
individual. So the myth might stem from the
fact that we have like a Costco membership card that employee
would have to check out to go make a purchase at Costco, but the actual
charge itself would be on an individual, an individual's named
issued credit card, and that person is responsible for those charges.
Okay. Awesome, thank you.
Okay, uh, I think Councilmember Wright already weighed in.
Councilmember Huish, is there anything else on this one?
Who's that?
No, I, I'm good with the things that
were hashed out. A lot of the stuff that you guys were saying were things
I was questioning. Anyone else?
Okay, thank you. That, that should be ready to come to us as well.
We'll bring that on the 16th. Okay,
thank you for your help. That's one we've been working
on for a long time. So we'll move on to item 1C, which is
Scenic Mountain, uh, the area rezone. There's 223 properties already
in there and assessed to it similar to our other ones, the historical zone.
Uh, so we're just looking to update this into a more current
zone that fits what's already there, and Mr.
Hobbs is going to tell us more about it. Thank you, Mayor. I think you
already described it quite well. As part
of the process of working through what areas of the city need to be rezoned,
we're still waiting for some direction on specific areas that might be desired by the
council as a whole. But we decided to start on the periphery, like you might
start on a puzzle, on the outskirts and working your way in.
So we chose the northeast area of the community where we still have old properties
that Yes. —that were developed as part of the Scenic Mountain Project. As you see
on the screen before you, of course, the location off of the parcel viewer map
of the county and an aerial view. There you have
a copy of the future land use map just for reference. And you'll note that
the lion's share of the area under consideration right now
is within the community commercial future land use setting
or category. And then the balance in— it looks like a neighborhood residential 3.
The intent is to change the zoning on the properties,
give them current zoning as was noted or expressed,
and then with that adjust the future land use map
categories to coincide or harmonize properly with those zones.
The Planning Commission had a chance to look at this and they had one minor
map correction and they were pointed to this QR code that took
them to a list That I'm going to show you now.
Let's turn it this way.
This is the start of the list of the 223
or so properties that we're talking about at this
moment, and you'll notice in there accounted for is their existing
feature land use map, setting a category, their zone, the proposed.
And the future land use designation
or category or setting, and then the proposed zone. So as you work your
way down, as with normal policy, streets have gone to the Ag Zone.
We've got some open space parcels that are intended to be identified
now as being one of 2 different open space zones.
Same with common space. And as you work your way down into the actual
residential areas, then you find NR-3 or NR-2.
Okay. with associated multifamily zone based or predicated upon
the number of units in a building tie best to MF-1 or MF-2.
And then the houses which are detached,
though they don't exactly fit lot size-wise, the closest we
have for them right now in terms of small lots is the RC
zone. And so just put them into that category.
Thank you. And that gives you an idea of what we're working
with on this first in this area
of more to come rezoning
efforts. Just one question.
With the 3 parcels at the north end that belong to
EGOT, is there any requirement for them to improve
the open space? My feeling is no. So we
rezoned the open space. I have a question for staff. I think we're going to
be making open space for commercial community. It's right along the SR-73 expansion that they're
going to do there. I think that as part of their expansion, they generally do
something along the roadside, but do we know? And if we
make it open space, is there any requirement for them to do anything with that,
or are we basically just at their mercy? I'm not aware of anything like that,
Councilman. I think we can just designate and be okay, but we'll still send a
notice, and if they have concerns, If they have concerns about that, they'll express them.
In this case, we're just in that work session mode to see
if it's an agreeable proposal with your group.
In my mind, I'm thinking if there's something that can be done,
maybe it wouldn't be a bad idea for us to explore what that looks like
along any of these types of state corridors, being that we're going to have another
state road going through our city that has a requirement for it to be improved
to some degree. whatever that is, at least weed mitigation, you know, et cetera,
along those. But if we don't have any capability of actually enforcing it, there's really
no point in that exercise. Is that something that you think you could find out
from UDOT if there's perhaps in other cities that
that exists along the I-15 corridor or any of the other state roads, if there's
an onus that's required to do something with that municipality or county or
whatever? And I can see that with the development project, But yeah, I'll certainly research
it. If they're not, then it doesn't matter. But if there is, maybe we need
to have a zone that's specific to those types of uses
along there. Makes sense.
Thank you.
Okay. Yeah, the only question I have is, uh, I mean,
we're not increasing because this is all developed already, so it's
not like we're granting any more rights. We're just trying to assign
what rights were given previously to a new zone. That's right. Sorry, a zone
that actually exists. Yes, that's the key. The zone that's on the books now
and can be used to answer questions to the private sector especially.
Okay, let's go online just to make sure. Councilman Huish, is your councilman right?
Nothing for me, thank you. I think staff should just bring
it back on the consent agenda. I don't think this one's going to have any
trouble going through. Okay, perfect.
Thank you. Sounds like you're good to go.
Um, that's all for our discussion items at this point,
so we're going to move on to item 2, which is the, uh, city manager
information items. Is there anything For the council?
I have a longer report for the regular meeting, but I
think I inundated you with a bunch of emails lately with a bunch of updates,
at least 3. You know, just know that the staff is working hard on budget
and projects, capital projects that are going forward, an exceptional Pony
Express Days, and a great appreciation to our events and our communications and
all the staff that help support that and the elected leaders as well.
And I think that's it, unless there's any
questions council has of me.
Okay, I don't hear anything from above, so we'll
move on unless those guys— feel free to stop me. Mayor, can I ask one
question? Yep. And maybe, maybe, Ben, you're waiting to do this in the
policy session, so I want to be careful, but I thought you were going to
at least offer some information about a chapel
application that might come in before us.
Is the chapel— I think— is there
something about the church house?
The rec— remember the rec hall, the height issue?
Isn't that on our policy section? Yes,
that's right, actually. Thank you very much, Brad.
Thank you. Got a million things in my head, and I appreciate
you reminding me about that. So I saw Mr. Baker in the audience, and I
thought we have to address this while he's here. Okay, that's good.
So during my report, one of the things I talked to Councilmember Wright
about was, was the fact that we, during our DRC
meeting, we had a Yes. ...request for some exceptions
to the recreation portion of the church that's
being planned right behind the Walmart area there.
And I believe that the 3 exceptions really had to deal
with the height of the recreation facility,
the wall that would be facing Walmart that
would be visible to the general public, as well as
some trees and landscaping So I'd like to, if I could, turn some time
over to Brandon to be able to talk to those to see if there's any
questions or concerns with regard to those potential exceptions
being included into a development agreement. I'm going to turn
the time over to Steven Layman.
And the ball keeps rolling down.
Actually up to the person who really knows what they're talking about, and I'm just
making it up as I'm talking.
I'd love to be able to clean that too. Keep it going.
I'll try to keep this brief so you can move on.
Um, yeah, like I mentioned,
there's, there's 3 points of conflict that we wouldn't be able to approve
the site plan as they presented it, so I wanted to go over those really
fast. Our purpose would be to seek a development agreement to be able to grant
those exceptions. So the first one is
our code requires— I'm going to try to show you both here—
that any parking lots larger than— again, I don't remember the number— comes from 87,120
square feet, requires a raised pedestrian walkway through
the parking lot in order to access the site. So there are—
this is the asphalt portion, so the parking lot is 91,000 square feet. Okay.
665 square feet. They are providing—
So what's it like they're not providing? So originally they were going to provide this
walkway that gets to the recreation building. This is ADA compliant,
as well as the one that would then cross all the way over to here.
We also asked them to put in an additional one that's shorter here, because I
think this one— I believe this one would probably get used more often, at least
to access the existing building with the remodel area.
So it wouldn't be necessarily raised, but staff
feels like it meets the intent. There's going to be ways for pedestrians to
access the site. So that's the first one that we'd have to deal with.
I don't know if you want to discuss these one by one or do you
want me to just review them real fast? Sure.
Okay. Second one is, as I mentioned,
the height. Typically, we have a 35-foot
height limit on these buildings. They're proposing 40 feet
as the max. Let me show you.
So 40 feet is what they're proposing here for the maximum
height. And then the
third one would be this wall. So this wall
would be facing east. I think I mentioned that is what is going to be
up against Walmart. So maybe
not as viewable from the general public unless you're standing behind Walmart. I don't know
what the view would look like from SR 73. We don't have
that yet. They did send us these renderings.
So you can see, this would be the southwest corner
of the Walmart property looking north.
So this is without the building, and then a mockup of what it would look
like with the building as far as the scale goes between the two. And then
their best attempt at putting that building in,
the trees will block some of it. It is at a higher elevation
than Walmart properties. Take that into
account. So those are the 3 asks that
you'd be dealing with in development agreement. So I think the applicant just wants feedback
whether you're willing to maintain those and whether we should pursue a development agreement and
bring it to council. Sure. What would be the purpose of— why do they need
40 feet?
I think when they talked about— so there's a basketball court included in
that recreational building.
And I think it's just to be able to— whether that's the
design of the building, they need the 40 feet the way they're laying it out.
I'm not an architect, so I don't know. But that's the reason we were
given. Is there any
view of what it looks like from the neighbors to
the north or Scenic Mountain looking south?
Because honestly, it doesn't faze me
by Walmart. It's like, that's the loading dock of Walmart.
It's— people aren't going there to take wedding photos. But is there
blocking anything or any kind of nuisance
that's coming from that? Are there any lights that are up on the higher parts
of the building that are going to shine into? I know that they have
issues with Walmart shining their lights down. They don't have to have the lights
on sometimes at night in their homes because of how bright Walmart is.
So like, is there anything to succinctly say
from the north looking south? Are there any issues with lights around?
Yes.
Not knowing where the lights would be, it's really hard to
tell. We don't really have a great— because
this would be— this is the best 3D we have. This would be the north
side right here. Um,
it's only going to be maybe 5 to
8 feet taller than what the current building that's already on the north end of
the property is. Yeah. So it would be the tallest building there, maybe not significantly
taller than what's I just— I'm inclined to let
this project move forward because there's been so many things that have built up
to it. It's a very unique situation. It's built specifically for
the people that live immediately adjacent to this property and some
people that are coming to visit the people that are immediately adjacent to the
property. I think that it's going to be a huge benefit to this neighborhood and
I think it's about time that they finally get to use their land the way
they wanted to. How tall are
the LDS chapels that have gym, the basketball courts as well?
What's the height of those? Not including the seat bowls. I think the
canonical tall is 35 feet. So they have
been able to successfully have basketball courts at 35
feet? It's only like the peak. That's the roof. The steeple can go
up to 70. So that's not including the actual size of the
roof inside the jambs.
I'm not really in favor of changing our styling unless
there's a very good reason to do those types of
things. If we're talking about steeple, I mean, that's probably something that we're
having a different discussion about, but this is This
is a recreation hall, and if
we do it here, that could easily be something that we have
to say yes to again in a different location. I think we've
set a seating height of 35, unless we're viewing
this as a commercial use now, which I don't think that's the case, in which
case that changes that. I don't know that it's really identified
that I can find. Specifically, this is a little bit of a gray
area. But I don't think they want
to have a commercial zone on this.
That wouldn't be beneficial to tax collection. I think
to me, 35 probably would not be unless there's
an appetite by the city to create a special
use when it's an ecclesiastical entity.
And I agree with Councilmember Wright, or Wood
here, because— so if we allow that here, I don't
see how if another ecclesiastical, like another— Like the
LDS Church. Like the LDS Church, for instance. So say the LDS Church came in
and applied and said, okay, we want 40 feet. How would we be able to
say no at that point? And I worry, I do worry about some precedents
with that. I think that height is something that is I
think that's a pretty ubiquitous rule that needs to apply through the city.
I'm more flexible on pathways. I think that's— I don't have any issues with that.
The fact that this is right up against that Walmart, I'm not
as concerned about the architectural features on that side as well.
That is a reasonable request, but I think the height does
open up other issues that we could bind ourselves unwittingly as
a council. Councilmember White, can I speak to that?
Mayor, may I speak to that just a minute? Yeah, go ahead. I'll just say
that, I mean, I've had a chance to probably digest this a little bit deeper
than most council. I know that most of you are seeing this for the first
time, and I've seen it for a few weeks. It came before DRC and had
a chance to think a little bit about it. And part of the issue,
as I talked to Mr. Baker, that they're having is that they want to do
both basketball volleyball in here, and they'd like and
have designed the building to be that tall, recognizing that they
don't want to bring plans forward if there's really no appetite by council to
consider making an exception
in the only way that is available to them through development agreements.
So we're not talking about changing code, we're not talking about a variance, we're not
talking about anything like that. The code would still stand for all other uses.
And in his very specific instance,
just like you said, Councilmember Whitey, it's a pretty unique location
in the city with a big box store
directly to the east. And so the question in my mind became—
and I listened to Councilmember Wood and I say, look, we don't want to adjust
the skyline. And my question is really—
What's the detrimental impact by considering that through development agreement?
I'm really interested in hearing that because from my perspective, I don't see
a lot. But that's why this is before council, is to really allow the
applicant to kind of take the temperature of the council to see if there's even
a willingness to consider this making an exception through development agreement. If there
is, I would be probably more favorable to that.
And if there's not, then, then he'll at least know the direction he
needs to go to be able to bring the project forward. Thank you.
So I'm just trying to think what are some other buildings
that are existing in the city that might have that use. It's probably going to
be the school, frankly. You're probably talking about their gyms. Do we know the
height of the gyms in our middle schools or elementary schools?
I don't. I don't know if that's something we ever look at.
So I would say that's probably a good place to start. Let's figure that out.
Maybe that's, maybe that's where we find the common ground
in that, that the different Do we
consider civic schools educational use?
Institutional educational civic uses to wrap that in?
Because I don't want to make exceptions, frankly. I don't
like that. I mean, I understand what you're saying, Brandon, about MDAs,
but first in usually creates a problem for us down the
road. We have experience with that. I'm not saying that. Rather than just saying,
okay, we understand the use, what they're trying to do,
let's address it so that the next person comes in, we already have a thing
in place that we're addressing it so that we're even-handed
in the way that we're addressing this. Because generally
speaking, if we already are there at 40 feet of the schools, then why does
it matter?
I think one— wait for you to finish that, but just
as a thought as well, You said civic,
and of course schools, whatever, but you know height is gonna at
least be a discussion. I don't know where everybody's gonna land, but when we started
in City Hall, some of our own, you know. So I
think, and that also could be specific to a downtown district,
which is different as well because downtown's different than everywhere.
I think you can make it as an exception in a certain area,
possibly, but— Yeah. Anyway.
I guess— sorry. I think the thing
is, to my fellow council members, some of the things that we have
said when people have wanted us to consider higher buildings
for hotels, or they wanted us to consider, you know,
X, Y, or Z, we don't want to put it in code is usually
what we say, because we're willing to look at the specific
circumstance and weigh the circumstance with the
impact and all of those things. And I feel like as
a practice, we as a body tend to make
these choices and changes through development agreement rather
than code because there's sometimes that we just don't want that code
spread far and wide throughout the city and it's very specific instances.
So for me,
I really look at this and think, if this was built in a neighborhood with
apartments, we probably wouldn't even bat an eye at it. Like,
and it's a special circumstance. It's a church
and recreation building nestled behind
a Walmart in a bunch of homes that are the people who
are going to use this specific property.
If it limits their ability to be able to do what
they want and need to do in the space, then I
think we should really look at it and say, is it
going to impact the neighbors? Is it going to change the nature or character
of the space or hurt the city in some way? And if it doesn't,
then I think we should consider it and lean more into property rights
and letting them use their property to its fullest capacity.
Okay. You've got two different arguments there. If we're talking about property
rights, those have already been established. There's a code that they follow; they don't
meet that requirement. So the answer is no. I'm trying to find a solution that
goes forward that creates an even standard. The next entity
that is a religious entity that wants to come and build something that has
a recreational use, what is that standard going to be? If we're trying to
do it so narrow that it can only exist. In this particular neighborhood on
this particular lot. I think that's a dangerous precedent because overall
I think I've been pretty upfront about I want this project to happen.
But I think we have to be careful when we start being too specific where
everything has to be this council is going to make this decision because the next
council may not have the same expertise in land use and it's
very easy for them to just arbitrarily just start saying yes to things without any
really a baseline for us. So for me, I'm trying to find—
The fact that you said volleyball, that was actually one of the questions I was
going to ask. It sounds to me like we're trying to get some height on
that. That's why I asked about the schools. Basketball, that's not going to be a
problem. There's plenty of height for that. But volleyball, that's a problem. You've got a
ceiling problem where you'd be hitting that. So I think this
is a discussion that's not even on there. I think let's get some information to
bring back to us and find out what the height of these other buildings are.
And then let's put something in place that allows for this to happen in these
specific circumstances. I'm not looking to say no.
I'm saying that for this specific circumstance,
in this way, we can say yes specifically to this.
And that way, when the next applicant comes to us and says we want to
build a recreation hall as part of our ecclesiastical whatever,
it's very easy because we've already laid it all out for them.
So, Steven, I'm going to come to you because we do need to get through
some more other things. This is a— we kind of need to move on.
Are you clear on where we're at, or do we need some— No,
I'd be curious if Councilmember Huish has any comments on that.
Oh, I didn't— yeah, Councilmember Huish,
if you want to weigh in. Well,
I can see both sides, both arguments. We want to
be consistent throughout the city. My questions are, are there any
surrounding properties where their views would be obstructed or
in the way? I tend to lean towards following
code, but I also think there could
be exceptions made. For example? Let's say that the LDS
Church wanted to build a temple somewhere in Eagle
Mountain. Would we have that same requirement that they keep
the top of the temple at 40 feet? I'm just throwing out a specific
example where, you know, there could be other religious exemptions
that would be made. So that same
question was through my mind, but the reality of it is I don't think that
They're stating this is their house of worship, this is a recreation space.
I think we want to make sure we keep those separately.
For anybody who's trying to do a house of worship, I think that
is a different category than what we're talking about here.
I'm sorry, can you repeat that? Being a religious organization owning property shouldn't give you
specific development rights to a
building specifically, in my opinion. Houses of worship should
have a standard that we follow that applies to everybody. Recreation centers
that belong to a 501 or belong to
a religious organization or a private organization ought to have a
standard that we're following.
I'm one person, by the way. If nobody else agrees with me, that's fine too.
I think it's not going to hurt to do what you asked Commissioner Wood
to to get some of the measurements. If we can get to a yes and
make a code adjustment that gives us a good framework moving forward,
great. And if we can't, then we can kind of battle that
out and get it to the place that we need to get to as a
body. So I'm inclined just to send Steven on his way and
tell him, bring us back information and let's move forward with that
discussion. Well, I'm kind of curious what we at Legacy
Center was, because if you had a swimming pool and then basketball courts They have
a, I think, a track that goes above. For instance, I think we— again,
this would be downtown. If we were ever to do a rec center, would there
be a height restriction on that?
Depends on what it looks like, right? So civic would be the
main question and location, whether it's downtown. So— Well,
again, you're talking about 2 different entities. Civic is us.
That's a different thing than a— Yeah,
it's for a use or an institutional use or a civic use. Civic would be
everyone compared to a private, say, 501, right, or something of that nature.
And so, and you could separate them. I just want to make sure that's clear
on the civic one. Um, so we're good?
Okay, so here's my plan. Correct me if I'm wrong. We're going to look at
other buildings, whether it's schools, see what their heights are.
See if it's feasible to drop it down or comfortable.
Possible code amendment, whether it's to separate if there's a
recreational aspect to these buildings or standalone building,
that could be adjusted. But then the other 2 items,
we could do a development agreement. I think we're looking for a
narrow scope of that, and then if not, to Melissa's point,
then it maybe needs to be dealt with in an MDA. But I think that
you can— we should be able to find a path through so that anybody
else that comes in a similar situation where they're trying to do recreational use,
that we have a standard outside the Civic, because the Civic is us,
and we have different rules for the city.
So, Mayor, can I ask one more question?
Yeah, go ahead. So the question is this: having,
having had some conversations, or at least listened to the DRC meeting. I think one
of the concerns in the applicant that I heard from the applicant is
just the timing of this. They're anxious to get started.
And so I think if there's— and
look, I, I, I, I think what the council is
saying makes a lot of sense, so let me start there. But I think really
he's going to walk away from this meeting and he's going to make a determination.
Okay, if I, uh, if I, if I If
I have to meet the height requirement, then I'm going to have to design my
building in such a way that it's 35 feet if I want to get started
right away, because this process that we're talking about is going to take a little
while to get to a place where it might function for them.
And so then the question remains in my mind, then is the council willing to
entertain a development agreement for the, the wall that's
just flat that's against Walmart and for the— Absolutely. Crossing guard issues.
I think those are the questions that we just need to be really clear about.
Sounds like the height is the hangup, but the other 2 are not,
perhaps.
Is it fair that if I said— now we don't have a lot of
closed session items, maybe just a little bit, so we can go a little longer.
But if this requires a little more attention and we need to massage this,
could we move it to item— I used to always call it item
19. But we can maybe come back to this and give it
the time it needs, or— I mean, it's up to you guys if you think
we can get there. Otherwise,
we can put a pin in it. I just want to
know for sake of time what you guys— if you want to try to hammer
it out right now, if we can get there, or do you want to— I
would say no, it's not on the agenda. So I think we need to give
him his instruction and let him go find that information and come back to us.
As an agenda item. I was just going to see if
there was a way to find out the numbers during the break, but also
if we are going down the code road, it's going to have to
come back, it'll go to planning, then 10 days from that it'll come notice
for us. Like, we're looking at at least 2 months out if we do code
for this, which is fine if that's what the will of the body is,
but if we want to help them move forward with
a development agreement, that's, I guess, the question.
But if this is what it's going to take,
I think the question that Mayor was asking us, though, you guys, is wall
and pathways. And I do not care about the
height of the wall or the pathways. Not the height of the wall, but the
look of the wall. So for me, yes,
absolutely, I could do a development agreement for Maybe everyone
else can weigh in. Let me throw one other question out there real
quick to the council, because— so what's preventing— let's say,
assuming that Cedar Pass Ranch had no HOA
that would prohibit it otherwise, what's preventing then someone in
Cedar Pass Ranch to come and say, well, I want a 40-foot-tall recreation
building? And we say, well, you're not next to Walmart. I mean,
That's hard to— it's hard to tell that person
no. I think that's what I was thinking
too, because there's not going to be a lot of other situations where you're
going to be stacked up against a Walmart and we don't care because it's the
loading zone of the Walmart. But I am cognizant of
the fact that— of what Councilmember Wood's saying, like, we're kind of setting the tone.
We have a unique situation as a body right now with the knowledge
pool that we have. So if we can get it right, that would be awesome.
But I think it's going to be hard for us to control it just enough
so we don't end up with a situation like that. Because right away I was
thinking, what if somebody wanted to do that in my neighborhood? What, you know,
and I'm glad that you brought up Cedar Pass Ranch because that's a very unique
area. And frankly, there's probably somebody there who could afford to build
a building like that. And I don't know that it would be something that would
work in that space. So I don't know.
So it sounds like, uh,
I'm kind of split 2 and 2. Gather information, come back with,
uh, hammer it out later. Well, Zach, you're the only one that
hasn't weighed in. You want to do an NDA, or do you want to have
them come back and we do a code?
Yeah, I tend to fall, uh, probably on the side of Craig and
Rich here, to have Steve go away,
research the, the next steps to bring
the building in line with code.
Okay. Yeah, I mean, I hate to hold people up, but our process is
our process, and I, I support that 100%. So If that's
the case, then you know what to do from— You mentioned you wanted that today.
I can find heights for buildings today. I think that's up to you.
For information's sake, you could pass it on to council, but I don't think this
is going to get addressed today, so it's going to have to come back is
what I'm understanding. So the question that I'm going to ask— this isn't even on
our agenda. We've already dedicated 20 minutes to it.
Why are we bringing this to this level where we're scrutinizing something
that isn't This was really
something coming from DRC, and the question was if this is not
a significant issue or concern of the council, maybe it's something that we could
have them go forward with because it was— because of
the timing nature of the construction of this. And so it was suggested, I suggested
during DRC with Brett, that maybe
this week take the pulse of the council on this. I think that's a good
idea. before we have them spend a lot of money and time trying to do
design work or spend time with our staff, with legal, if the
council is not inclined to move forward. Or we just wanted direction from the council
before we began. I guess one thing too, I mean, the applicant's here.
What I would be curious is the height of make it or break
it for this project. Or in my discussions with you,
you always have Plan A, B, C, and D, and I'm just wondering if
there's Another option that could allow you to move forward? And if
given the feedback that we're okay with the wall and we're okay with pathways,
is there a path forward for you guys? And I'd
like to give you feedback if that's the case. So, Mayor, could we just ask
him that question and have him answer?
I'm a little bit torn. I, I was going to bring the applicant up earlier,
but again, it's not on the agenda. And if there's 3 people that are saying
bring him back, I don't I don't know that I— I feel like I got
to respect the will of the body on that. So if others are okay with
that, then I'm at your mercy. I just want to make one comment. I think
it's dangerous precedent for us to start doing this.
Why are we making a special consideration? Every applicant should
have the same route to be able to bring something before the council. And if
we're doing it not on the agenda, what's to prevent that from happening in the
future where everybody else should have And by the way, I'm in favor
of your project. But I just felt like there's a reason that there's a rule
of law that we follow. And if we're going to circumvent that just because
we're trying to move something quicker, then we're opening ourselves up to
other people saying, why do they get special treatment? I just think that's
a bad process to sit in. It's not on our agenda. I think we've
given some instruction and we need to move on. Okay. I think that's where we've
landed unless anybody changes their mind. That's, uh, I don't mind that
it gets brought to our attention by no means, but I think the amount of
time we spent is sufficient. So, um, are there any other
items that you want to— Okay, perfect. Then I think
we're gonna move on. So you're good, Steve? Okay,
thank you. Um, we're gonna move to the consent agenda items just
to make sure we have enough time.
Um, and we have a lot of staff members as well online,
so I just As we go through these, we might need to make sure.
I think Brandon, is Debbie Hursties logged on yet?
I know he said he was planning
on jumping on. He's on according to
Lacey. So we'll start going through.
Let's see, we'll start the meeting with the recognition,
then we'll go down to the consent agenda.
Okay, number 11, bond releases and marketplace town center. Center out of warranty.
And just stop me online as well. Just holler if you, if you want to
stop. Uh,
12. Sorry, with the bond release, is there anything
about the condition of some
of the inner project roads and
parking lot that would have any bearing on whether
or not it's out of warranty and it's met all of its
Because it's pretty rough over there, and I don't know if we have any power
to help facilitate it being improved or
not, but— Who's best to answer
that? My understanding is that we get documentation from
engineering saying that it's ready to go out of warranty because they've done their
checks. So yeah, so that particular project,
I'm not aware of the specifics, but— I remember placing— it's going out
of warranty. They've done their due diligence. I imagine Vince
has been on this. Would you check during the break to see? I don't know
if he's online. Is he online? He is not,
no. Just check with him and give us an update before
we— when we get in a regular meeting, I'll ask for an update on that
one. I assume that the process
has been met, but given the Just
the reports from that area, we want to double-check that that's— that we didn't miss
something. To Melissa's point, I think we've had at least
a loose discussion about the requirement of them to have
a safe drivable surface in these commercial— because
we talked about this with another user up in North End of the city.
What is the Mark, I don't know if you're the person to ask this
question. What is the standard of them making sure
that they don't have missing asphalt or it's got
this huge dip that can cause damage? Is it because it's private property,
there's nothing we can do, or what is the standard?
So where are we specifically talking about? This is in Town Center. There's a
specific one that they're talking about, which is just right over here, right?
Yes. So when we're doing the— they can't
force someone to bond for private improvements under current state law. That didn't used to
be the case. But so when we're
talking about public improvements that we're inspecting,
when we're doing that, we're inspecting, you know, city sidewalks that are dedicated
to the city. We might go into warranty. When they come out of warranty,
we're inspecting them again. You know, other subdivision improvements, things like
that. So roads, infrastructure, that kind
of thing. We're not inspecting the private property,
like, you know, parking lot. Their interior roads would be considered parking lot,
correct? Their what? Interior roads that are part of the parking lot would be
considered private property? They can be. It depends on the situation.
So this is probably not part of that. Yeah, so if it's a private
road, we wouldn't, you know, that's part of, you know, we wouldn't inspect that.
So this is part of that anyway then? Well, one other question too,
are lights a part of that? I know that in a regular subdivision,
there's streetlights that are a part of the obligations,
but there's a light— Like sidewalk lights or something? Yeah, like one of them
got hit like probably a month into this development,
and it still hasn't been repaired. Is there any obligation
that they have? Because it talks about one-year maintenance period that's required
in their development agreement, and I'm just curious. Right. Again, if it's a private improvement,
we wouldn't ordinarily inspect that unless there was something specifically in the development agreement requiring
that specific thing. But wouldn't lights in the parking lot be
a requirement of being able to build in the master development agreement anyway? Yeah.
I mean, if it's code requiring an issue, and I'm not sure what. I don't
know what the code says on that off the top of my head. Then that
could be a potential thing. I don't know if that's a warranty issue, that's more
of a code compliance issue. Got it. I think it—
this question will come up more and more because we're having more
and more commercial areas, and we're going to start seeing more and
more of them leave the warranty phase. So,
um, some of those questions are important
to me because I want to make sure that the things that they're required to
do as part of their development are actually done and maintained
so that the safety is there for our residents.
So I was just looking at what the code says here. This is in 1630.060,
where it talks about the release, and council may approve phased release
portion of the funds of bond as work proceeds, but at least 10% of the
total shall be retained until all required improvements are installed,
inspected, and accepted. If any required improvements are not completed, the city shall
use as much as necessary of the escrow account or improvement bond to complete these
improvements. I don't know if that really states how you can
force that if they have something on the property that's private property.
under state law that we can't collect bonds
on private improvements. Does that include lighting if the property
has damage on it when we release it? Yeah, so again, lighting, like in a
parking lot situation for commercial development, I think that would be more of
a potential code enforcement issue than a bond issue. Okay,
thanks. Does that make that clear,
Melissa? Yes. Okay, so we're
good on that one as far as leaving it on the consent item. Everybody's satisfied
that they've met the allegation, and we will ask for just a clarification if
that's okay. Uh, 12A, the May 19th minutes.
Uh, 12B, minutes from the work session May 26th.
Okay, 13A, resolution of Eagle Mountain City,
Utah, authorizing the mayor to sign So I just
wanted to make a comment. Why do you need to bring this to us?
I mean, it's, it's not expending money, it's asking for it. Why isn't it
something that the mayor can just do without having to come back to us?
The mayor doesn't dare do anything without permission. Well, again,
you're not expending money, you're asking for it. It's a bond. It's a grant.
Excuse me, grant. Yes, go ahead, Kimberly.
The reason specifically that this one is coming is because it is a requirement
of the grantee. In order to grant to us, they require us to
bring it to council. Okay,
and I think there is, if I remember right, the Community Services
Board worked on this one and Steve.
If— was there a presentation, Steve? I know Jesse's here as well.
Yes, I can do that real quick.
Let's see.
Yeah, first I'd like to, uh,
apologize that the presentation wasn't included in the packet. It's,
uh, of course it happened all at the same time as our Pony Express
days and everything else, but, um, but again, this is only
coming to you because of,
um, the requirement from the county.
And can you see my screen? Is that
working? Yes. Okay,
perfect. Okay, this is annual funding that's provided to cities
based on the census population estimates. And so this year there's
$25,369 available for Eagle Mountain.
Um, this type of funding is generally for tourism promotion,
development, operation, and maintenance of cultural facilities,
recreation facilities, or And
they call it the recreation grant, which tells you that a majority of the
time these are used for recreational facilities. Some of
the past projects we've approved or we've received the funding for
include the cemetery gazebo. There's a trailhead being worked on
currently that was last year's funding, playground equipment,
asphalt trails, and others. Okay.
So our options are— June 8th is the deadline for
the, for these, uh, the submittal of the application.
And we need to submit the application
to use the funds or an application to hold the funds until next year,
which those would then add to next year's total.
And we'd have something like $60,000 or so,
$55,000, $60,000 next year.
The Community Services Board discussed this recently at their last meeting and
made the recommendation to submit the application to complete 1
or more asphalt trail connections that are missing
in the older neighborhoods of the city center area.
And generally, and Zach's probably there in the meeting, but, or David,
but generally these are the cost estimates that We
can look at for asphalt trails. It's right around $25 a
linear foot just for the materials. If you're looking at the cost
for doing the work in-house and you include
the labor and materials, but don't include equipment,
vehicles, or benefits, then you're at about $66 a
linear foot. If we contract it out with the design and
everything, you're probably closer to $90 a foot. Okay.
So these are the— what I did was throw together 4 trails
that I've talked with, um, Jesse Southworth about,
and I know she's there in the audience as well,
um, as the, the chairman of the board.
This first one is in the, um,
Pioneer Edition area. It's approximately 400 feet just
north of Pioneer Park. And those costs there, the $26,000
to $36,000, is based on the, um, these numbers
here, the $66 and the $90 per linear foot.
So there's, there's one missing segment there. That's a
possibility. This is a photo showing that area looking
from the north to the south.
And then the second one we looked at is a
much more narrow area, much longer. It's just a
little further east from Bob Graham Boulevard down to an existing
trail on the south. It's about 730 feet
long. The 3rd trail
is further southwest, so it's just east of Walden Park.
And you can see the trails in Walden Park, so this would extend to the
east. This portion, the 925 feet, is just
that east-west portion. Okay. That connects the 2 roads.
And hey, Steve, sure, just before you go on from that
one, go back. Yeah, that I see, I know where that one's
at. On the far right-hand side of the red line, that's that piece that's up
for disposal, the behind the Moody's. Is that for
sure where it kind of curves? I'm just wondering, is that
within— outside of the disposal piece? The,
the red, the red line doesn't have to be exact. I was
just trying to tie it into the existing sidewalk there, but it could, um,
it could swing up however we need it to, to connect,
as long as it's on our property. That, that property just to the south
is private property, if that makes sense.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, that's, uh, part of the Patterson development, I believe. Yep.
Right, that's right.
So that's what that area generally looks like.
And then this 4th one
is the north-south trail that's just attached to that,
um, proposed trail. This would connect all the way down to Eagle
Mountain Boulevard on the south, and it's about 1,200
feet.
Again, through kind of a narrow area, but a missing trail segment there.
And this is what some of that area looks like.
And then the last one that I'm showing is a trail that
wraps around the northwest corner of the Eagle Park subdivision.
And then on the bottom there, you can see another segment that potentially connects
over to Antelope Meadows, I believe.
And what— Meadows is a little further west.
Um, can't think of the name of that subdivision off the top of my head,
but the one just west of Eagle Park. So this is about 1,400
feet is the, is the portion up in Eagle
Park. That's the only missing segment that wraps around
that subdivision. So just a few
other considerations. If we, if we completed this in-house Just
to note, which we can do, but our streets crews would be diverted
from other projects and other maintenance.
The other kind of larger question is, should any of these areas be
considered for land disposal rather than trail improvement?
That's maybe a question for another time, but before we
just jump in and move forward with it, with,
you know, considering all of these trails. Well,
there may be some of these that make more sense to dispose of if
they have other connections or options on sidewalks where others
make, make a lot of sense to improve. And then if the cost of the
trail is higher than the grant amount, do we have the funding available to make
up the difference? Um, that's all
I had. So anyway, really what we're looking for is for the council to
consider options and authorize the mayor to submit
an application Or at least sign the application and give us direction on
which, uh, which trails or trail you're interested in, or if
you'd rather wait until next year and look at something else.
So I just wanted to make sure that Council Members Wright
and Huish could see the presentation. I know— Yes,
Mayor, we could see it. Okay, so this is some of the stuff
where Council Member Huish says he wants to see that asphalt machine. Working a
lot. So this is— this will be to your, to your wish,
and I'll go ahead and start online. Then Councilmember Huish, I see your
hand raised. Yeah, my thought around the
different options, I think ultimately we should try to work to do all of these.
The project that seems furthest along where there are
property rights being realigned Is
the trail number 3. Steve, if you could pull that up, that connects into
Walden Park. If you go east in Walden
Park, there's a trail that just ends right at the road that carries
into the— into those backyards. And I think we're pretty close around having
the property disposal, so we know where those boundaries are going to be.
Those conversations have been had. And Mayor, to your point, where that
red line connects in, I think there's I don't know if it's a 20-foot
gap or 30-foot gap where that will be able to connect in
there, but I would consider starting with that one since it's furthest
along in the conversations around where those boundaries will be. It would tie
in nicely to Walden Park there and give some good access.
And that's a pretty good easement on both sides. There could be some
other development that could happen. I don't know what that gap is between those fences.
Oh, it looks like, Steve, you've got it. Those boundaries
realign with the yellow marks. Is that, is that the property disposition
that we're looking at? Not, not necessarily.
Okay, okay. The yellow, the yellow is the parcel map, right from
the parcel map. Gotcha.
That's my only thought. Ultimately, we should probably just address
these one at a time. I think this one's furthest along. And I
just wanted to make sure— I know the, the red line's just kind of in
there for reference. But I would have
a question for y'all if you have, if you have a preference. If that walking
path goes one side or the other, right down the middle,
one of the things on that particular one that's on the screen was the,
the neighborhood talked about doing like some pump track type stuff or bikes.
If the path's right in the middle, it makes it to where you could do
less of something else on either side. So would
you prefer that path on one side or the other?
Ask the neighbors what's the direction, give staff on
where that path goes. That is, I think, 90 feet wide roughly,
or 110, I think, maybe before the disposal. I can't remember.
I think he tucked the path closer to one of the, you know,
private property lines. On either side. And to leave that space open for other
things down the road. Okay, that's why I was asking that. Does anybody else have
a preference on that as far as direction?
Is this setting it in stone? Isn't this just asking for money
and then— Yeah, I just want to make sure. Is that the case when
it comes back? That's what I'm asking. We have to submit for the
specific trails. This funding is basically guaranteed as
long as we submit the application. Does the application require you to
identify the location, Steve? Yes.
Okay. Well, well, the, the agreement for sure afterwards
The letter has to identify the location. I've been told that the application does
as well, but, um,
I— they have very little information provided for
this application from the county side.
So I think we can at least say that it's in that path,
but whether it shifts right to left, we could work that out. I just want
to make sure that before we go building that conversation's had,
Steve. Oh yeah, yes.
And if— I think the location of the trail within this,
within this parcel, uh, we can submit a map
and just show it, show it on one side or the other, but we can
set that in stone later as we, as we, uh— As
of right now, this just came to me, but the, the north side
has a connection in the middle of the block, so it would make more sense
to Put it on the north side and the south side. It does not connect
to the south that I see. So I would think the north side
boundary line, but once we have that disposal worked
out. So any other questions? Councilmember— oh, I said online.
So Councilmember Wright?
Maybe we lost— oh, you know what, I think he did say he might
have had to jump off, but he's on here. Do you see— we'll
pass. Councilman Wright for a second.
Um, Councilman Clark, anything here?
You guys? My only question is, just before we start
tackling in the neighborhoods, are we— have we
connected along our main thoroughfares for safe routes,
specifically Pony Express, you know, on the west side of the road?
between Lone Tree down to the high school. Where are we
at with the completion of that trail? Should we try to finish
those major trails first before we start diving into neighborhoods?
That would be one of my questions. I think the west side and the east
side had a gap that somebody's asking about. Is that right?
That's correct. There's a gap on the north end.
Yeah. So, I mean, if you want to
prioritize that, Steve, is that a possibility to prioritize
that one as well? Or if the appetite was too low, I heard Councilmember Huish
say tackle them kind of one at a time. But does that one need to
come up? I'm not familiar
with gaps up there except that all along the east side of Pony Express Parkway,
basically from Bobby Wren up to— what?
Up to— Lone Tree Parkway, there's missing
trail. I guess there's a new trail at the church that was just built there.
Yeah, I'm not talking about the east side, Steve. That's all undeveloped area.
I just want to know, do we have continuous trail from Lone
Tree onto Aviator on the east side? I believe we do. I believe we
do on the west side. West side, not east side. West side.
Yes. I just want to make sure that all our paths where the schools are,
that we have continuous path. for the kids to walk.
And if that's the case, we think that we've accomplished that. The next question would
be, do we have the same thing existing on Eagle Mountain Boulevard? I would say
that to me, those have to be probably our priorities, where we know that we're
walking to and from high schools, middle schools, and elementary schools,
and then we can tackle its interior. And, and that's
a great question, and there are a couple of missing segments on Eagle Mountain Boulevard
that are, um, I think too difficult for this,
uh, to work through for this application based on the ownership.
Steve, can I ask you a question? Sure. I'm assuming
you're, you're proposing these 5 connections
because they're closest to the grant budget, and it looks like this one,
for example, would be $60,000 to $83,000. If we go
out like a longer stretch, it's obviously going to cost more.
Is that why we're looking at these 5? They're just closer to the grant size.
That's definitely
one reason. The, the Community Services Board wanted to look at
missing segments within city center neighborhoods,
and so I basically went on the aerial photos
and scoured the neighborhoods and found in the, in our oldest,
our oldest neighborhoods, which segments were missing that
hadn't yet been improved. And then I did look along the roads as well
and, and identified 2, 2 segments
along Eagle Mountain Boulevard, like I said, but they're, um, they're not owned
by the city currently. Thank you. I know there's some
in, in, uh, Meadow Ranch as well, but I think if we could focus
on City Center, and it would be lovely to see
one of these every other month just getting knocked off the list.
This seems like a good one to start with.
Okay, anything else? Any more questions?
We're good on that one. Okay, uh,
13B is a resolution to go out to City of Utah approving a service
contract with BCS for third-party building permits
and plan review and inspection services.
This is Brandon
Larson. Yep, I don't know how much,
uh, information you want on this one, but, uh, we're just trying We're
trying to rework our existing contracts. We've historically worked
with WC3. We're kind of exhausting them
and wearing them out a little bit. So that's
a little bit of a joke, but we've got a lot going on and
we need additional help. And so we've— and also
in talking with other jurisdictions, it's not
uncommon. to contract with multiple third-party outfits
to help with inspections and reviews. And so BCS is a really,
really good third-party outfit.
A lot of the old— a lot of
the people that we've been used to working with at WC3 actually are now
at Building Code Solutions.
We've begun working with them and want to enter
in, and in talking with Melissa, the idea was like, well, let's get WC3
and BCS to enter into 5-year
contracts, service contracts. So got this one ready for
BCS and should be bringing one for WC3 to you here shortly.
So if you have any questions, I'm here to answer them. Thank you.
Seeing none, we'll go on
to 13C.
Anything online? I told them to speak up if there was, so I kind of
paused. Hopefully, um,
okay, we're going to move on to 13C, uh,
Resolution of Eagle Mountain City approving the Community Service Board rules and regulations.
This is another one we do have Steve online and
Jesse, the board chair,
here. And I don't know that there was
a presentation, but for questions, is that right?
That's right. The Community Services Board reviewed this a couple of— at both of
their meetings. We made a few minor changes at the second meeting
and then recommended approval.
The one question I had, maybe it's redundant in the
language of the— the language that's
here, but I wanted to add the word trails to Article 2, Section 2.
And I gotta pull it up myself to remember what exactly that was, but I
think it's the purview that the Community Services Board has.
And it didn't mention trails. I think it mentioned parks and recreation or
something like that. It didn't specifically call out trails. Okay. I thought it would be
helpful to, to add trails to that.
Yeah, that makes sense. It's, it's called scope of review,
um, the matters considered by the board— parks, recreation,
arts and cultural programming, etc. So we can add trails,
certainly. I think that's a good call out.
That's a good one to add. Did you
have anything to add from the board? Nothing? Any other
questions from online?
Nothing? Okay, with that one add, just make sure that goes in
the motion. I think when we do the consent agenda, we can leave it on.
And we will move on to item 14A.
Ordinance, Eagle Mountain City, Utah, repealing and reenacting section subsection
8.15.08 OG,
Eagle Mountain Municipal Code, regarding construction work during restricted hours. This is something
that's come up a lot lately about Working specifically
indoors after hours, but then also on some of our major roadways.
So any questions? Let's see, that's David
Salazar. Do you have a presentation or just— Yep, I can give a— I've got
5 quick slides if you want. Can I go through?
Okay. Okay, so the proposed amendment looks at updating
the noise category for Section G for construction work
during restricted hours. It removes— it moves
authority from City Council to the city engineer or or a designee,
which aligns with the current traffic control code. It does
maintain the requirement that City Council be notified for all upcoming nighttime work,
and it also has provision for emergency work exemptions, which currently we do
not have in code. And then it allows for coordination for
conditions and other property notifications. So why the change?
This was from comments from City Council a few meetings back.
About just how we can continue to improve efficiency with the city
by you know reviewing each kind of project on a
case-by-case basis to see when it makes sense to have work occur off hours while
still maintaining your guys being kept in the loop.
This would reduce project delays as far as getting projects out
to bid, issuing contracts, things of that nature.
So some of the criteria that's in the code. It does prioritize
public safety first, so when we're doing offsite work, we would look at
things as traffic flow management. For example, there's a project coming up this summer
at SR 73 and Ranches, which we're going to recommend for nighttime work
because we know that's a very busy intersection and we don't want to try and
reduce congestion there that's already present.
This would also look at material placement, utility ties-in. And just
trying to minimize impacts to the public and just safety in general.
Some of the safeguards we have imposed is that it gives authority to the city
engineer, also requiring you all to be notified prior
to work started. Then it also has a provision
there about notifying property residents and
businesses in the area. And then, as I mentioned, it also adds a provision
for emergency work, which is limited to city and utility-related operations.
So, you know, your neighbor Joe can't go dig up his driveway in the middle
of the night. So that's kind of all
I've got for that code section. Happy to answer any questions.
Seeing no questions, we're going to move on. So yeah,
I just had a little pause to make sure. Ordinance of the City of Vermont
City, it's 14B, Ordinance of the City of Vermont City approving a franchise agreement with
the Forge Fiber 37 LLC, a subsidiary
of AT&T. I know Marcus has this one. It's a franchise agreement for more fiber
in our easement, right? Am I
saying it right? Go ahead. Yeah, I mean, so in order for a telecommunications
company to perform work in the right-of-way, they need to get a franchise agreement
that sort of outlines the rules
of what they're going to follow. This is in addition
to any sort of permits that would be required for specific
work being performed in the right-of-way. So AT&T,
their subsidiary Forge Fiber 37 LLC,
is seeking a franchise agreement under the 1996 Telecommunications
Act. You know, we're required to grant franchise
agreements on a nondiscriminatory basis for telecommunications companies.
And so we negotiated a franchise agreement starting with our template
as kind of the baseline, and we kind of filled in the details in relation
to things like the bonds required and things like that. And kind of some of
the, you know, they're asking for a little extra time on notification
in relation to if they have to move their stuff because of a public project,
for example, or expanding the right-of-way. They need to move their equipment,
you know, they're asking for 60 days rather than 30.
So that's kind of the baseline, but if you have specific questions, I'm more than
happy to respond.
I didn't see in there, and maybe I completely missed it, but are
they going in any specific location, Marcus? So that's kind of
not part of the franchise agreement itself.
So they would come in with a specific application for like
an excavation permit in order to go in the right-of-way, and they would
have to submit that type of documentation then. Okay.
Any other questions on that one?
I know Councilmember Wright had to jump off because he's having a meeting up there
at that conference. He might have a question,
but not that I'm aware of, so we'll ask him in a minute.
Then that is the end of our consent. So as far as scheduled
items, like I mentioned, 17A has
been removed. Is there anything that we need to look at before we
go on break on any of the others? The public hearing,
15A, has to do with the disposal of property,
I believe, in that same area by the Walmart.
There's also The
bond that we've talked about last few meetings,
the— that's item 16A. Anything we
need to address on that? Mayor, I did just want to let you know
on that particular item that I do have Brad Patterson
that is on the line if we have questions. We would want to
preferably maybe talk about them if we have time in this work
session, but if If not, then they will stay online as well.
And it's Brad, you say? It is Brad Patterson
with Gilmore Bell is online. I have some background information I can give
if the council has it, but I just wanted to let you know that he
was online. So if there's some questions that we could get out now, that would
save him from having to stay, unless you think
it's a bigger conversation than that. Do you think— you don't have any
questions on this one? And online,
uh, Council Member Huish, are you— is this item going
to require a large discussion? I know we talked about it last time. I'm just
wondering if, uh, we could ask Brad his questions now, and then, uh, if not,
he could be let free for the evening. Yeah, I think
our maybe only question was— Brad, welcome, good to have you with
us. Thank you. I think the only question was, do we need to
specify whether we And just a
disclosure, I won't be voting on this issue, so I'm just asking,
but do we need to specify if this is going to be a
callable or non-callable bond issue?
Not at this time. Eventually, when the bonds are actually sold
into the market, the call features will be determined at that time.
Awesome. That's the only question I had. Thank you.
So just one other, just one other point
that I wanted to point out is that following the City Council meeting,
there will be a meeting of the Redevelopment Agency as well.
Yeah, at that point in time, that's when the, the bonds will be issued,
uh, and one of the, uh, actions will be taken at that point
in time is to authorize the execution of an interlocal agreement.
And the city will also be taking that action as well. So if
anybody has any questions with respect to that item that's going
to appear later on, I'm happy to discuss that at this point in time too.
Otherwise, I'll let you get on without having to
be bored by bond nerd stuff. We like
bond nerd stuff. I do.
So if it— as long as— yeah, and Brad, I think
as long as Kimberly or Lacey have your number in case it does
come up, we can I could get a hold of you and get you back
online. But I think, uh, from what I understand, it sounds like we got a
handle on this. I know Kimberly's also well-versed, so, um,
I think we wouldn't need you to come back. I don't think— Exactly.
That's always an option. And I think, Kimberly, you do have my cell
phone number. Just ring me up, and once I hear from you, if I need
to jump back online, I'll do so.
Perfect. Thank you. You got a message? I sent Brad a text
and said if you have a question about this, send it to us so we
can ask the question in the policy session. He does have a
question? If he does— oh, okay. Yeah, if he does,
we'll— we can come back. And most— and most of the questions I bet we
can answer here as well. So we'll see if we can get back to that.
Thank you. The last item is a discussion we'll take
care of in the and policy. I think they're— I put this on here on
purpose for— I think we
have a little bit of work to do before the 16th, and I dang sure
want to get as close as we can before the 16th. So that discussion
should be robust and exciting. Also, just one other quick
thing is that after that, we will have the RDA meeting.
Kind of on that same item we just talked about, not the budget, but the
previous one with the bond. Is there any questions
on the RDA portion? It should be pretty much the same.
So we'll have that RDA meeting right
after our regular meeting. With that, I think we're good.
We do have one item that should take about 30
seconds, just an update if you wanna hear it, as far as a closed session
item. Yes. Oh, that's right, there's 2 items I just told
you about. So, Mayor, I move to adjourn to a closed
session pursuant to Section 52-4-205,
subsection 1 of the Utah Code Annotated.
Second. Second. Okay, we have a motion by Council Member Whiting
and a second by Council Member Clark. And I just want to make sure,
Council Member Huish, you have a a code, a link to get
in, and he'll be joining us, right? I know Councilmember Wright might be
tied up for a little bit, so we'll start the vote.
Councilmember Huish? Yes.
Councilmember Wood? Yes. Councilmember Whiting? Yes.
Councilmember Clark? Yes. Okay, we'll adjourn to closed
session at 5:57.
Okay, we're good to go, and I will, uh, welcome everybody here.
It's a full house, thank goodness. Uh, before we call this
meeting to order, I have asked Kimberly, to open us with a prayer.
Our Father in Heaven, we are really grateful for the opportunity we have
to gather here at the City Council meeting. We pray that thy Spirit may
abide with us, that we will be able to listen openly,
that we will know that everybody who speaks and come forward
Um, does so with the best interest of Eagle Mountain City at heart. We pray
that we may be led, guided to make the decisions necessary,
that we'll be able to help our community be a
place where all feel welcome and a part. We're thankful for those
who serve in our community, in law enforcement and fire and
throughout the military, and those who may be serving abroad, and ask thy
Spirit may be upon them to strengthen them as they fulfill their duties and responsibility.
We're grateful for this great land that we live in and pray for the leaders
of this nation and our state. In these things we pray, in the name of
thy Son, Jesus Christ. Amen. All right,
thank you, Kimberly. And, uh, at this time it is 7:02,
and we'll call this policy session, City Council, the 2nd
of June, to order. And, uh, the first thing that we
will take care of is, uh, we've asked Finn Coffett
to lead us in the Pledge of Allegiance. So, all rise.
I pledge allegiance to the flag of the United States
of America and to the Republic for which it stands,
one nation under God, indivisible, with liberty
and justice for all.
Thank you, Finn.
First of all, I wanted to excuse— the dais is a little empty tonight,
but they are online, I believe, with us. Are both council members
online? Yes. Okay.
Brett Wright and Councilmember Zach Huish. Are out on city business
and doing other things, and a lot of our staff as well, uh, at a
conference talking about water and other, other needs. So,
um, they are joining us but online, and I hope they represent
us well up there on their other assignments.
Um, moving on to item number
7, just making sure we get everybody squared away here
because you're going to get called on, Ben. Yes, sir. I'm kind of stalling for
you, but item 7, there's some information on this.
Thank you, Mayor. Um, I do
have a few. Thank you very much. So upcoming events,
Eagle Mountain City Library Summer Reading Kickoff is tomorrow, June 9th,
from 10:15 AM to 11:15 AM at
the Friends, um, In Need of Animal Sanctuary.
There's Bring carrots or celery if you would like to share a
treat with the animals. We have a food truck rally that begins Thursday in
the east parking lot of Cory Bee Ride Memorial Park from
6 to 9 PM. Farmers market begins this Saturday
morning at Cory Bee Ride Memorial Park from 9 AM to 1 PM.
Motivational mile is this Saturday, June 6th, at Cory Bee Ride
Memorial Park from 1 PM to 4 PM. Thank you.
Pony Express Days Demolition Derby is this Saturday, June 6th,
at Pony Express Memorial Arena at 7 PM.
The Pony Express Rodeo is next week,
June 11th through the 13th, at Pony Express Memorial Arena,
and tickets for the Demolition Derby and Rodeo can be purchased online
at ponyexpress-events.com. And then, Mayor, with your
permission, I'd like to read a statement if I could.
Mayor, council members,
and members of the public, um,
tonight I have the privilege of recognizing 2 individuals who contributed to Eagle
Mountain City, um, whose contributions to Eagle Mountain
City have left a lasting mark on this organization and our community.
Faina Kofod and Laura, um,
Armentrout will be honored during a retirement celebration on
Monday, June 8th, However, with this being the last
council meeting before Finn's retirement, and with her prominent and public leadership role,
I wanted to take a moment to honor her service during this council meeting.
Finn has dedicated many years of her professional life to serving
the residents of Eagle Mountain. During her tenure, she has served in
a variety of critical leadership roles, including city recorder,
administrative services director, and most recently, assistant Thank you.
Throughout each of these positions, she has consistently demonstrated professionalism,
integrity, and unwavering commitment to public service.
In local government, there are people who perform their jobs well, and there are
people who become part of the institutional foundation of an organization.
Fin has been that foundation for Eagle Mountain. She possesses a depth of knowledge
about the city, its history, its policies, its people that simply cannot
be replaced. She has helped guide this community through tremendous growth,
organizational change, countless elections, major projects,
and thousands of decisions that have shaped Eagle Mountain the Eagle Mountain we know today.
Public service is often measured in projects completed,
budgets managed, or policies adopted, but the true legacy of a public servant is
found in the people they influence, in the culture they create,
and the example that they leave behind. Finnan's legacy will
be reflected in the many employees that she has mentored, the leaders she has
supported, and the high standard of service that she has modeled throughout her career.
On behalf of the mayor and council, city staff, and the residents of Eagle Mountain,
I want to express our sincere gratitude to, uh, Fainu' Kofod
for your years of dedicated service. Thank you for your leadership, your friendship,
your wisdom, and your countless contributions to this organization. So please join
me in thanking I move to certify Yulia Kofet for this outstanding service to Eagle
Mountain City, wishing her a happy and well-deserved retirement.
Second.
Now that's pretty cool. I love seeing
that. I hope I don't have to do very many of
those in my time here. I like to see people stay.
Finn, I might put you on the spot. Just a chance to say one
minute of the— we get 3 minutes of public comments, so I'll give you 3
minutes to— Is that all
I've earned? Yeah, I would expect
somebody to say 30 seconds. I just want to give you a chance to speak.
Thank you. There's a reason that I have to stand up to
see Mayor, Council, and staff, because I'm so short.
But simply put, it's been
my absolute I wasn't prepared
for this. Sorry. 30 seconds.
It's been a privilege and an honor for me.
I've seen the city go from really nothing
to what it is today, and it's because of
the heart of the employees and the residents within this community that
we've been able to grow to To a city of almost 80,000
people. And my husband and I were just talking about this recently,
about our claim to be— our being out here.
And I'm proud to say that, yes, we took a chance. We were
the first connection to city utilities phone
number back in the day. I know that there were other residents out
here, but we came out, we took a chance.
We had no idea what we were getting into.
And the fact that I've worked with some amazing
people. I can't remember the countless
number of mayor and council members, but pretty much all of them.
I don't think I've served under Debbie, or a couple
of others, but I value the friendships and
the relationships. Thank you. that I have developed along the way and those
that I've worked with. And you are in good hands.
We have an amazing city administrator— city manager, excuse me—
who cares about the community so much so that he moved
up here and bought a house. Ben, in the short time that I've worked with
you, I truly appreciate your leadership and guidance. And I have
absolutely an honor, the greatest honor and respect for the Office
of the mayor and the city council,
and I became citizen during
the process of citizen
and the ability to vote. It meant the world to me,
and I respect that role. So I appreciate your service,
and I'm just happy to say that future
Tuesday meetings are going to be dedicated.
So come on out Monday at 4 o'clock to honor Finn
and Laura. Okay,
thanks, Finn, and thanks for all your service. Um,
next item on our agenda is item
number 8, and we'll turn that over to David Yuleberry for a recognition of graduates
of the CERT program. This is kind of a cool accomplishment as well.
Okay, thank you, Mayor, Council. Uh, Dave Ulibarri, Public Safety Director
and slash Emergency I'm happy and excited
to present to y'all our, uh, 4th year 2026 CERT
Team CERT internship graduates from, uh, Cedar Valley
High School in Westlake. Uh, we have our biggest class we've ever had in
the history of our program with 17, uh, 13 of which are here
tonight with their families to be recognized. I have a short, uh,
just under a minute slideshow to kind of give you a grasp of what they've
been learning. Uh, it is a semester program, uh,
for each of them, and they graduate with 5 national certifications in emergency
response. And at the end of the year, I bring both semester, uh, interns together,
and we do a mock disaster over at the school where we have actors,
and I bring in my makeup artist, and we make it as real as possible
and make them very uncomfortable, and that's when they learn the best. So I'll
show you real quick, and then we'll get into the certificates.
That was at the end after our simulation. Here is fire extinguisher
demonstration. We teach them cribbing to lift and move heavy objects upstairs. Someone who was
pinned. And this was our— from our moulage and our triage exercise.
We also learned CPR, stop the bleed as well.
We also take a visit to our fire stations, and that's always a highlight for
the kids. Teach them different ways to lift and move people,
and we do group training exercises as well.
And this was Halloween, so I wanted to spotlight that one. Xander with
the, uh, very high quality Jack Skellington.
Surely you're not saying that's the only time you dress like that.
Oh no, that was just— I didn't realize it was Halloween. It was just Thursday
for me. Yeah, these kids know I take my drip really seriously.
So I'll read their names and then we'll hand them their— what they'll be receiving
tonight is their Community Emergency Response Training certificate,
which is sponsored by Homeland Security, and their
Stop the Bleed certificates, which is sponsored by the Department of All the other 3
were emailed to them through email for their online FEMA
and their American Heart CPR. So without further
ado, first we'd like to recognize Axel Rubio. He is not here today.
He is in Army basic training. Yep.
He is a— he was an early graduate and he started basic training in the
Army. We're proud of him. He's been there for about 4 weeks now.
Ryan Easley.
Here. Okay, Xander Osborne,
Jack Skillington.
Yeah, I didn't say this and neither did they, but go ahead and line up
right here after you graduate, just left to right, and then we'll get a picture.
And we'll do a picture or something. Thank you.
Next, we would like to recognize Kaiser Roca.
Logan Bennett had to work tonight, and so Gwen will accept
on his behalf, as well as Kaylee Roberts did
as well. Everybody else, I think, is here. So Avery Sherman,
come on down.
Uh, Colton Miller.
Thank you. Congratulations.
Kenzie Reed.
Cleo Craig, was she able to make it? I didn't see her come in.
So Cleo Craig, also we'd like to recognize her.
Dallin Roberts, he's out of town as well.
Kalea Lecker, was she able to make it?
We had a few go out of town right after graduation.
Understandable. I know for a fact Delilah Snell's here. She's Front
And Cadence Rideout.
Thomas and Kate Westmoreland.
And last but not least, we are going to want to recognize—
and this, this girl, this young woman will take a couple minutes
to address council and mayor, just wanted to speak on behalf of the
group for a couple of quick minutes— and that would be Laura Gallardo.
Hello, I know you guys have a very long meeting, so I'll keep this
brief. As you guys just heard, my name is Laura Gallardo,
and I had the opportunity to do this
internship this past semester. I first heard about it when I
was in my junior year during a career fair, and I saw Dave set
up in the little booth, and I walked up to it, and I was like,
whoa, this looks pretty sick and like pretty valuable information.
Yeah, these are— Our class schedules, you should definitely look
into it, and I'm very, very glad and grateful that I had the opportunity
to take his internship this past senior year and this
past semester. Obviously, he already went through a little bit of
what we learned, and so I won't take too much time talking about
that. The biggest takeaways from this internship for
me was not only the certifications that I'm walking away with, but also the
the connections and the, you know, more durable
skills that I've learned and the soft skills that I was
able to exercise and practice with during this entire internship.
I am very grateful that I had the opportunity to learn about so much things
that obviously you guys already have in place and preparations and
emergency response levels and managements.
And so I'm really grateful that I now have the confidence to not only
have that information and those tools for myself, but to also have
that and feel a little bit more useful when I'm going out in the world.
And, you know, it gives me a little bit more confidence as a young woman
to be able to know that if the situation ever arises,
which we always hope that we can avoid those situations, I'll be able to
help people when it matters most. And so thank you to
our amazing mentor, Dave. Round of applause for him.
Sorry, I'm just gonna say something really fast. So my
name is Gwen Whiting. I'm the internship teacher at Cedar Valley,
and Dave and I started this program 4 years ago— mostly him. I just
facilitate the students and grade their assignments. But Dave
is not one to toot his horn sometimes, so I just wanted to share something
that was sent to us by a former CERT
students. It says, hey Dave, Schaefer here from last year's CERT
class. I wanted to let you know that partly because of CERT, I have now
gotten 2 scholarships. Both are centered around community
engagement and service and together total $11,500.
What might have seemed like a small commitment on my end has
really paid off. In case you're wondering, I am currently studying— English.
econ analysis degree here at the U and will be doubly—
double majoring in legal studies with the hopes of going into
law school and eventually federal law. Thanks again for being such a great, awesome teacher.
And he sent that to me, and this just goes to,
like what Laura just said, these connections that these kids make through
these— this internship is amazing, and we couldn't ask
for a better mentor or someone to teach teach these kids these things that they
will be able to use for the rest of their lives. So thank you,
Dave.
Okay, thank you. Now, Soraya, I'm going to give instructions for you.
Everybody needs to move to my left, this way, right? So center of
the screen that way. So tell us— that's good.
Well, not too far. Tell us when.
So she just wants to get a quick picture. Does that work right there?
Turn and
squeeze in. Are they okay now?
And if you can't see me, I can't see you. So just picture everyone's like
in a window.
Okay, you should have one. Thank you.
Thank you, guys. You're welcome.
While we're waiting for this to clear out, I'm proud to announce that we have
2 mayors from former— former mayor from other cities, so welcome to the
How many mayors have come to Eagle Mountain? 3. 3? Where's— Oh,
Mayor Foreman too. I heard of his name,
but I didn't see him. So yeah, we have 3 mayors with one of our
own and 2— yeah, that's kind of fun.
I heard his name, but I didn't see
him. Okay.
Just letting the room kind of clear out. We have a full house, and now
there's some seats if the rest of you want to filter in. Those who are
online, you're missing this. It's standing only.
We are ready to move on, and we'll start The
next item is public comments. So time has been set aside for the public to
express their ideas, concerns, and comments. Just for
information, item 17A has been removed.
So if you're here to speak on that item, you're welcome to speak. You can
speak about anything you want, but that has been removed. It would be a public
hearing otherwise, but it's not tonight. Yeah, so there's
a number of people that came to speak on that, so they can use the
public comments. Okay, yeah, I just want to make sure we're clear on that.
It will— it was noticed as a public hearing, so it'll have to get noticed
again as a public hearing. And you'll still have the next
public hearing whenever— It was the Horizon—
Yeah, Horizon— Ordinance
of the Wyoming City approving Horizon Master Development Plan. So that's one that
will come back. At a later date, so the
public comment is limited to three minutes each person. I will open the
public comment period at 7:23. As a reminder, public comment is an opportunity for community
members to address city council, and each speaker is allowed up to three minutes.
If you wish to speak during the public comment portion, please complete the form in
the back and then return it to our city recorder Lacey
over here on the side. City members or council members will listen
but not engage in discussion during public comment. Disruptive behavior,
personal attacks, or comments about individual city employees are not
permitted. If you have issues or questions regarding staff or
personnel, administrative staff will meet me in the foyer for discussion. I'm going to ask
that Finn take care of that. Is that okay? And,
uh, if anyone's here to speak about any of our public or our
staff, Finn will meet me in the foyer. Lastly, public comment
period is We will now open the floor for items not associated with scheduled public
hearing. If your comment relates to a public hearing item, please wait until that item
is called. The public hearing items tonight on the agenda are 15A, which is a
resolution of Eagle Mountain City considering disposal of a portion of Utah County
Parcel 453260109.
So if you're here to speak on that item, uh, you can wait until
that item is called in 15A. Any other item that you wish to speak
on, we can do it at this time. And we'll go to Lacey.
These first couple did know that it was the first of the team, so we
can go through these if they would like to speak. Holly Thomas.
Would it be possible to bring up the map? Or is it— are we not
going to be able to bring up— can we bring up the map for the
development even though we're not— apparently it was pulled again. It was the second time
it's been pulled. Yeah, I don't believe we have a map,
so— but the council's familiar.
Okay, just because I was going to show that my property comes up right up
to it. I've got 10 acres that we built. So the
ridgeline ordinance is kind of what my concern is. Again, I'll be coming back.
This is the second time I've come and it's been pulled.
It looks like 2018 was when they first passed the
original ordinance. Scott Hazard bought his, uh, his— that property
in 2022. Um, so that was kind of my concern, is they's
claiming it's grandfathered. Um, I'll backtrack a little bit. I've been in
Eagle Mountain since 1998. I lived in Cedar Pass Ranch. I've seen this place grow
from, you know, the polygamists and one street in the city center and
us in Cedar Pass Ranch. So I've seen the city over the last 28 years
change. The ridgeline is a big concern because
you can see that for miles and miles. It's not just Eagle Mountain.
You can see it all the way to Lehigh. I care about Eagle
Mountain. I care about the character of it. I think this would be
a dangerous precedent to allow building up on it. I personally own
ridgeline property. Part of my 10 acres is on a ridgeline.
So, I mean, my brother-in-law has been itching to develop, and I
would rather not see homes up there. And I think
this could open up a whole problem if one person's allowed
to disregard the ordinance. I feel like that can just lead to other people justifying
it. Another concern, our house was built up right up on
the hill too, not on the ridgeline of course, but the blasting. We did not
have to do any blasting, but we've been here for blasting, and we have felt
our house shake because of blasting. And with our home,
they had to bring out a pick. I just, I'm really concerned about the damage
to the ridgeline, the hillside, if they're going to try to go in and try
to blast through that rock, because we are on solid rock up there.
And so the other thing that I'm concerned about is looking at the map,
and I saw there are only 2 means of egress, which I saw that map
and I thought, that is a death trap. I have spent more time
than anyone up on that hillside. Because again, I own 10 acres. I walk daily
with my dog. The fire risk is out of control. I mean, it is,
it is bad up there. It's all very dry. The conditions are extremely bad.
I have found— I can't even tell you how many campfire rings
I have dismantled personally. I even found a lighter by one of them.
Kids go up there, they build their little campfire rings. It's just a matter of
time before we have a fire up on all that vacant land.
I'm just Concerned about the fact that a fire would go right up the
hill. 30 seconds remaining. And so, and also we're not even allowed to have fireworks
in the area. Second thing is the wildlife. Todd Black— I'll come back again— he
literally sat in my dining room talking about the, our, our 10 acres
and what we can do with it, uh, and the fact that they actually changed,
had us change our property to open space. And I have seen
coyotes, I've seen foxes, I've seen, I just I saw a fox
the other day. Hawks, rabbits, I've seen everything up there. And I'm just concerned
about how this development will affect the wildlife. Again,
last thing is— Your time is up. I got it. Okay. Thanks.
D'Lynn Anderson.
Sheila. Sheila. Okay. Sorry, everybody.
Sheila. Yes, because I asked for them.
This one as well for 17A, Cole Thomas.
Hi. Yeah. My name is Cole Thomas. I just wanted to speak
a little bit about this, the possible development of homes on the ridge lineup by
the cell tower here in Eagle Mountain.
And I wanted to start off by saying that building these These homes don't really
have any positive contribution to our city at all.
The first concern I'd like to point out is, I mean, I grew up here.
I know Eagle Mountain has curated a very welcoming suburban aesthetic,
particularly surrounding natural beauty. So rising above a lot of our houses are these
beautiful juniper-covered hills. They serve as a sanctuary for wildlife and
they provide access to nature for our Eagle Mountain residents.
And building homes right on top of that hill is just going to serve It's
going to serve as nothing more than an eyesore. As well as aside from this
issue, the main thing I want to point out, one of the main things I
want to point out is the fire issue, how building homes on
top of this ridgeline is going to be a very large fire hazard. So first
off— First off— Building roads that are going to access these homes
at the top of the hill are going to be very expensive. It's going to
be very difficult, as well as it's going to be very hard for things like
fire trucks, ambulances, and police personnel to access it. So considering the
fact that it's a no-fireworks zone because of the dry landscape, a fire that isn't
dealt with immediately can quickly harm a lot of the residents in the area.
So developing homes on this ridgeline would be
very much a hazard to the people who live in the area. Next thing
I want to talk about was the dark sky ordinance. So one of the specific
parts of the dark sky ordinance is that there's
limiting rules on how high lights can be because the The more elevated lights
are, the more they contribute to light pollution.
And putting these houses right up on top of the hill, they're going to
contribute more light pollution than any of the other houses in here in Eagle Mountain.
One of the things I wanted to say is here in the state of Utah,
we've had a bit of a bad track record with a lot of our
governments and local legislators allowing millionaires to ruin
our our neighborhoods, whether that be from mines or
the new data center that they're building in Box Elder County.
It's been a problem, and you guys have the chance to change
that, to do something different. So that's my time.
Also for First Amendment, Paul Scott.
Terry Roland.
Hello. I feel like I'm about to repeat a bunch of what you've already
heard. I, the first lady
that talked, I second pretty much everything
she said, except for I don't live in Cedar on that side of the hill.
I live in Lone Tree Ranch. I've been out
here since 2004. I am alone
in my home. My husband passed— sorry,
my husband passed away in 2020. I worked my butt
off to pay my house off so that I have security.
I'm 60 years old. In this economy, I can't
afford to sell my house and move. I have 3 dogs.
I live a block away from the bottom of that hill. The blasting
that we've lived through already, I get anxiety,
my dogs get anxiety. There are veterans
in my neighborhood. I can't even imagine what they
go through. And it's not even blasting like by our
house. When they're out there doing their drills for
Camp Williams, my house shakes.
So now ask yourself what that's going to do when you move that blasting
10 miles closer to my home. I want to know
who's going to be responsible for the inevitable damage.
There's homes at the very bottom of that hill. I live one block over on
Ficus. When my foundation
gets shaken till it cracks, when windows get broken, who's going to pay for that?
I'm not turning that into my insurance. That is
not a natural disaster, and I didn't do the damage.
And I'm not going to go to litigation with some property
developer that has millions of dollars and can put me off for however long
and pay me 10 cents on the dollar for a ruined home.
I feel like if you go ahead and put this through, it could happen to
someone else. And I don't have anywhere to go. And I'm
not the only one in my neighborhood that's at this age.
So why would you let them do that? That's nothing
but rock bed. There's animals that
live there. I don't want my house full of mice. When they developed those
homes down below my house, that's what happened. We got
infested with moles, mice, snakes,
scorpions. They displaced all of those animals.
And I know you guys don't care about the animals, but some
of us do, and I don't want them living in my house.
Please reconsider doing this.
It's going to cost a lot of people a lot of money and a lot
of problems. Think about the veterans, if nothing else.
I'm unsure if this one is for 17
as well. Tracy Knight. Okay. Tracy Knight.
Well, let me just state how much
I love Eagle Mountain, and I retired here, and I'm going
to mention a word that will make you shudder from Southern California.
Okay. And I want to live in Eagle Mountain,
not in Southern California, because Southern California had
really bad development plans, as in no
plan, and it was all driven by real estate developers.
And I know people impacted by the fires
in Southern California this past year and lost
homes, and it was uncontrollable. And what I would like
to know Is what part
of Eagle Mountain receives notifications regarding this,
these meetings for this project? Is it all of
Eagle Mountain? Anyone know?
If you want to finish your comment, this is not— Oh, okay,
then you'll find out. Okay. Because if it's anything
but all of Eagle Mountain, shame,
because this impacts everyone. And I'm especially
concerned, have you changed the current, the variances
that we have had on slope and street width in
order and approved it for this project?
Have you changed variances? Yes. And if so,
why? Who approved it? And what are the checks and balances
that went up against that?
Also, I have heard rumor that you're allowing
a narrower road width for this development,
which also it's not. And it was said, well, they will all have
parking because they'll have garages. It's not about parking.
I understand that. Fire engines cannot get
up there, but they're dealing with it by having sprinklers in the house.
Yes, every fire, every brush fire starts in a house.
That is a safety concern, and the egress out of there,
people in a fire, they're not going to be able to get out.
As Holly Thomas said, it's a key safety risk.
And then how do you justify to us the
variances? Is that true? Have slope variances
been changed? And you can tell like
everyone who's here, I suspect, is pretty upset.
So does anyone want my last 30 seconds?
Okay. I'm going to go sit back down. And I
still love this place, but don't make me be
unhappy about living here because I don't want to move. I have too much stuff.
Thank you.
I'm going to— so I want to just answer a couple questions. I think it'll
help for the general public. More specific,
not just to that comment, but I just want to make sure everyone knows nothing
has been approved on that development. That's the developer asking
for approval. Nobody allowed smaller streets.
Nobody's allowed anything at this point. That's them asking and
proposing that. The council has a decision to accept
or deny that. So the, the, the— I think a
lot of people online and here in person are saying that who's allowed
this, or why did you allow this, or how come this is going forward this
way. I think that's a good question. It's not going forward. It's them asking if
it can go forward. And it's up to the council to decide
if they need— why, you know, if they can have that exception or not.
So the decision has not been made is what I want
to make sure everyone understands. There's no decision been made yet. There's just a developer
that's asked. You're welcome to come and ask if you can put a 70-story high-rise
on your lot. Probably won't happen, but you can ask. I'm not asking.
I'm just saying that it's— so we can't, we can't speak without
the mic, so, um, I'll ask you to be quiet. But it's a—
I'm just pointing out anybody can ask. Nothing's been approved.
So just know the council is fully aware of, of the asks and the exceptions,
and whether they grant them, you know, it will be— maybe we
don't know. I, I can't speak. I don't know what they'll decide. So I just
want to make sure that's clear. So to move on—
That concludes all the ones for 17A that I had. So the regularly scheduled
ones, we have Holly Reimer.
Hello. So I'm here to speak about
the extension of the road in Silver Lake, the neighborhood,
Silver Lake Parkway. I just want to start by
sharing my appreciation for all that you guys do for the city. I know that
you guys have a pretty thankless job and that you guys put in a lot
of hours, so thank you for all that you guys do for our city.
I understand the concerns regarding increased traffic on our major neighborhood
roadways, including Golden Eagle Road. My own house sits very close to Golden Eagle,
and I'm out there driving it most mornings between 7 and 7:30. I know
firsthand what the current flow looks like, and in my view, absorbing more traffic
is absolutely worth it. We simply cannot expect a brand new high school to function
safely or effectively without— with only one way in or out.
Beyond traffic disruption, this extension is a matter of student safety. Right now,
it is practically impossible for students to safely walk or bike to the new campus
due to the lack of sidewalks on the south side of Pony Express Parkway.
Our kids deserve safe and dedicated routes to school. This extension provides
exactly that while simultaneously giving us an entire neighborhood
a vital route in and out of our neighborhood.
For the safety of our students and the long-term infrastructure of our community,
please consider extending Silver Lake Parkway.
Jeff Bean.
I want to echo the same comment, and I don't have too much to add
about extending that road so that we have a connection from Silver Lake neighborhood
to the new high school. The main thing I'll add is just I
think we're still waiting for a traffic study, and I think that'll be very informative
in putting data to what we're trying to express. But I think if you look
at the, you know, essentially the satellite map view of that area,
Like, the houses are in our neighborhood. So I think the concern is that people
are going to cut through our neighborhood and use that as a back road to
get to other places. But I, you know, I think if you look at where
the houses are, they're in our neighborhood. So the people who are going to be
using that road are the ones in our neighborhood. We have a huge density of
people in Evans Ranch and Silver Lake neighborhood. And all those
people are looking for a way to escape the, you know, driving past
the Silver Lake Elementary School. And it might help get some
people in our neighborhood using a different route,